Und das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Leute, da bin ich, bin ich irgendwo für eine Viertelstunde aufgewacht.
Oh man, gestern haben noch versucht, das fertig zu bauen, was wir im Stream angefangen haben.
Ich hab mein komplettes Addon kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab gedacht, ich mach das viel eleganter als gestern im Stream und irgendwie geht's jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Das überträgt nichts mehr außer die statischen Einträge.
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, irgendwas stimmt da nicht, aber ich mach heute weiter.
Das wollte ich gestern Abend nicht mal weiter basteln.
Ich hab's komplett kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab's gepusht und ich hab's zum Glück noch nicht.
Master gemerged, sonst wär's jetzt bei allen kaputt.
Ich weiß nicht genau, warum's kaputt ist.
Ich guck mal, ob's immer noch kaputt ist.
Ist immer noch kaputt, okay.
Ist immer noch kaputt, ich hab grad nachgeguckt.
Keine Ahnung, warum es kaputt ist.
Muss man nicht verstehen, lul.
Na ja.
Dantudev, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Moin.
Small access point auch am Stand.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ich's kaputt gemacht hab, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil gestern, das hat ja funktioniert.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Du, du, du, du.
Overwatch 2, ich hab's noch nicht gespielt.
Ich hab auch keinen Bock, ehrlich gesagt, Overwatch 2 zu spielen.
Overwatch 1 hat mich zu sehr fertig gemacht.
Wo ist eigentlich der Singleplayer-Modus?
Hört mir grad so an, nicht der Singleplayer-Modus.
Der Co-op-Modus müsste da eigentlich hin.
Sollte Overwatch 2 nicht...
War das nicht das Erste, was die gezeigt haben von Overwatch 2, diesen Co-op-Modus?
Diesen...
Diesen, äh, PVM-Co-op-Modus?
Den gibt's gar nicht mehr, oder?
Also sprich, das Erste, was die gezeigt haben, ist jetzt noch nicht mal im Game, oder wie?
Ansonsten hat Overwatch 2 nicht wirklich viel Neues.
Es sieht ein bisschen besser aus, hat ein bisschen weniger Maps.
Es hat ja weniger Content.
Aber...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Nee.
Jetzt will ich...
Ganz ehrlich, ich will's gar nicht spielen.
Wieso bist du hier am Hardcore-Overwatch-Kriden?
Also...
Ähm...
Weiß nicht, also...
Nee, ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mein, es ist free-to-play.
Vielleicht lad ich's mir runter und spielen wir ein paar Runden.
Aber ich kann...
Nachdem ich mal ganz brauchbar in Overwatch war, ja...
Ich kann da dieses, dieses rumge...
Wie würde ich sagen, das rumgepimmelte...
So, ohne dass man was auf die Reihe kriegt, nicht haben.
Außerdem hat mich Overwatch 1 so aufgeregt, auch durch die Entscheidung, die Blizzard, also was Blizzard mit dem Game gemacht hat.
Ich glaub, ich hab da keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Oh, ein Gamepad.
Ich hab nicht mal eine PS5.
Ich hab eine PS4.
Erste Generation.
Und die hatte ich insgesamt...
Wo liegt die überhaupt?
Das ist die da oben, ja.
Ähm...
Ja.
Die hatte ich vielleicht insgesamt vier Stunden an oder so.
Also die letzte...
Also die, die, die vorletzte ist es ja eigentlich, ja.
Konsolengeneration war richtig wasted.
Ich hab hier eine Xbox One stehen und eine Xbox...
Nee.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Moment.
Xbox X, Series X ist die aktuelle.
Ja, genau.
Ich hab hier eine Xbox One stehen und eine PS4 oben drauf.
Nur noch die 360. Ich hab von allen drei wahrscheinlich die 360 die letzten Jahre überhaupt am öftesten an.
Ja, drüben im Wohnzimmer hab ich auch eine Switch stehen.
Das Problem ist, es gibt irgendwie keine Games mehr.
Das einzige Games, wo ich echt Bock drauf hätte, wenn es rauskommt, was jetzt übrigens auch demnächst ist...
Yep.
Das ist nicht mehr lang, noch drei Wochen.
Ja, da hätt ich Bock drauf.
Aber da warte ich lieber bis es auf den PC kommt, bevor ich mir für ein Game eine PS5 kaufe.
Oder ich guck mir ein Let's Play an, wobei ich mir die meisten Let's Player nicht geben kann.
Das ist echt so früh.
Excellent.
Und sonst hab ich irgendwas spannendes verpasst.
Diese Woche war irgendwas.
Jetzt machen wir mal ganz kurz, gucken wir mal in die GitHub Trends Weekly, ob ich nichts verpasse.
Okay, mehr Image Generation.
Notepad Next, come on.
Wir haben so viele Editors, brauchen wir allen Ernstes noch Notepad++ jetzt Cross-Plattform?
Man hat es ja von abgesehen, theoretisch konnte man das sogar relativ gut in Wine laufen lassen, wenn man es sich wirklich geben wollte.
Ein Cross-Plattform Notepad++. Na okay, meinetwegen. Soll ja jeder machen, was er will.
Ich meine es gibt tausend Editors mittlerweile.
Es kommen täglich neue dabei.
Ja, Fleet ist rausgekommen, verbraucht 4GB RAM.
Ja, hab ich mitgekriegt.
So, dann gibt es irgendwelche Typescript Datenbanken, die lenken auch Critical Information.
So, dann gibt es, das klingt irgendwie wie Machine Learning vom Namen her.
GFP gun aims at developing practical algorithms for real world face restoration.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Wie restaurate man denn Faces?
Ach so, man hat Fotos und die werden dann verbessert.
Sodass sie aussehen wie HD.
Ja gut.
Man muss einem dann halt jedem klar sein, das ist nicht mehr das original Foto, was man anguckt.
Das ist, was AI denkt, wie das Foto aussehen sollte.
Was ist Fleet? Das ist ein Text Editor, oder? Naja, also eigentlich eine...
Ja doch, ein pluginfähiger Text Editor von JetBrains.
Der irgendwie aus Gründen, die sich mir nicht so ganz erschließen, einen gewissen Hype hat.
Also ich mag das JetBrains Zeug, ich verwende das auch für fast alles.
Aber für Fleet habe ich keine großartige Ahnung, was wüsste ich nicht, wozu ich das verwenden soll.
So, alles brauchen wir nicht.
Warum gibt es ein SQLite Fork?
Warum wurde SQLite geforkt? Habe ich irgendwelches Drama verpasst?
Is das SQLite nicht?
Ist das nicht Open Source? Ist das nicht Open Contributors?
Also was ist, warum ist...
Okay.
Ach so, die wollen irgendwelche Zusatzfunktionen in SQLite einbauen, die die original Maintainer nicht haben wollten oder sowas?
Na gut.
Rust, was sonst, Alter? Was sonst?
Hätten sie es nicht Blazing die Fast rewritten in Rust machen können?
Für mehr Rust-Fanboys, die am Start sind.
Noch mehr, noch mehr AI?
Alter, ist ja zum Pfirschen aus teilweise.
Ach du Kacke.
Rust Text Editor, wo wir es gerade von Text Editors hatten?
Hast du mal überlegt, die IDE komplett wegzulassen?
Ich habe das alles schon gemacht, aber gerade für Sprachen wie...
Also gerade.NET und C-Shop ist abartig.
Das willst du nicht in Vim oder gar in Emacs oder sowas machen.
Das ist nix.
Das hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Chinese Zeug in Massen.
Chinesisches Pfeilfahrzeug.
Remote Job Companies.
Das haben wir schon ausprobiert, hat nur teilweise funktioniert, aber ganz brauchbar.
Better Discord.
Ist da irgendetwas in Germany dabei?
Tatsächlich, Massive.
Better Discord, was macht das?
Add Plugins and Themes to your personal copy of Discord.
Plugins zum Beispiel, Node.js war es sonst.
Discord selbst ist ja eine Elektron Anwendung.
Und warum?
So ganz erschließt sich mir der Sinn jetzt noch nicht.
Was kann man damit dann Geiles machen, was man mit Discord nicht machen kann?
Bros Plugins.
Call Time Count.
Das ist natürlich ganz nice.
Es ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sowas wie FFZ oder so für Twitch.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Das muss man sich mal angucken.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Du haustest deine Software, also du haustest den Quellcode deiner Software meistens auf
GitHub heutzutage, wenn es Open Source ist.
Es gibt ein paar Microsoft Hater, die sagen, man muss das Ganze auf GitLab machen oder
auf Bitbucket oder so, weil GitHub ist böse, aber die meisten hausten es auf GitHub.
Und dann können in der Regel Leute sich das angucken und Änderungen vorschlagen bzw.
Änderungen einreichen und entweder nimmt die der Maintainer, also der Besitzer, entweder
übernimmt er die oder nicht.
Also das ist quasi so eine, wie heißt das, wie nennt man das heutzutage?
Collaboration Plattform.
Leute, ich muss am Montag halbe Stunde Presentation halten und ich habe sogar extra ein paar
Buzzwords drinne.
Kommt zum Beispiel drinne vor Infrastructure as Code und Traceability und was habe ich
sonst noch?
Ein paar Buzzwords, ich glaube, das ist Zukunftsteil.
Da freuen sie sich alle.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache Buzzwords.
Massive Buzzwords.
In das zweite Wort, nee, ganz so schlimm ist es nicht.
Gestern hat mich einer gefragt, ob ich bei Ihnen in der Firma zwei Zeiten bei einer
S5-Steuerung anpassen könnte.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was eine S5-Steuerung ist.
Gute mal, irgend so nen Fertigungsherstellungs-Dings-Roboter-Maschinen-Ding.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Siemens, bestimmt Siemens, oder?
S ist bestimmt Siemens.
Ich weiß, dass Siemens in dem Bereich voll verbreitet ist.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung, was eine S5-Steuerung ist.
Was ist eine S5-Steuerung?
Excellent.
Oder auch nicht.
Mehr Tabs?
Hier, guck mal, ich habe schon ein paar.
Lul.
Didn't know I need this.
Never flash a USB drive.
Warum nicht?
Soll das sein?
Das ist für eine fette Kiste.
Das ist doch kein Ersatz für einen USB.
Oder ich weiß nicht so genau, was er uns erzählen will.
Aber das ist viel zu fett für einen USB, Mann.
Huge.
Pepofet-USB-Ersatz.
Das Gute an USB-Sticks ist, dass sie nix wiegen, klein sind und mittlerweile sogar relativ viel draufpasst.
Ich meine, gibt er schon saumäßig billig 228 GB USB-Sticks und mehr.
Max, was macht der Darkfischer, wo du vielleicht Zongrollen hast?
Das startet irgendwann im November oder so?
Aktuell haben die Beta, aber Beta habe ich gerade keinen Bock drauf.
Gerade weil die Leute, mit denen ich spiele, nicht am Start sind.
Beta.
Also wann die genau releasen, weiß man nicht.
Aber irgendwann halt jetzt so in dem Dreh demnächst.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt schon relativ viel los für Beta.
Am Ende muss man halt sagen, kannst du mit der Population nicht wirklich das Spiel spielen.
Aber naja.
Wenn das schon in der Beta so ist, rechnen wir das mal mal drei oder so, dann kannst du schon halbwegs spielen.
So 1500 ist natürlich besser.
Ich meine, am besten ist es natürlich, wenn es voll ist mit 3000, 4000 Spielern.
Aber ab 1000 kannst du halbwegs spielen.
Ein Kollege sprach mal von einem Forum.
Das ist ein Forum, bei dem man fragen kann, ob jemand ein Programm hat, für das man selbst braucht.
Du meinst Fiverr.
Du meinst Fiverr, oder?
Fiverr kannst du Leute beauftragen, Sachen für dich zu programmieren.
Das ist aber, naja, naja, was man da kriegt.
Sagen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel, können wir mal irgendwie Software?
Ich weiß nicht, was man da gescheit suchen muss.
Custom Software Web Applications.
Ja, also da kannst du Fiverr, kannst dir sowas kaufen.
Sag mal was, ich suche Twitch.
Nee, da findet man nur Emotes.
Software.
Software Entwickler, ok.
Da findest du dann teilweise Inder.
Da findest du dann teilweise Inder, die für 5 Euro angeblich eine Webseite erstellen.
Hier, I will develop Web Application.
Ich habe davon mal Just for Fun, so ein paar Inder beauftragt, das war alles Scam.
Also weiß nicht, wie es hier aussieht.
Basic Web Application, 10 Euro, und dann schreibst du den anderen, sagt er, ja für 300 Euro könnte man das machen.
Die sind geil, ich meine, ich verstehe das für 10 Euro, dass keiner macht.
Das ist keine Frage, ich würde das auch für 10 Euro nicht machen.
Selbst wenn ich Inder wäre oder China-Chinese, der arm ist und absolut kein Geld hat und jeden Dollar quasi brauchen kann.
Aber für 10 Euro würde ich das nicht machen.
Aber warum schreiben sie es dann hin, dass sie es machen für 10 Euro?
Das verstehe ich nicht, da soll man etwas realistisches hinschreiben.
Ich habe euch ja mal den Quellcode gezeigt von dem einen, der das geliefert hat,
der eine Schleife gemacht hat, um das erste Element aus einem Array rauszuholen.
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern?
Das war eines der weird champigsten Source Codes, die ich je gesehen habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das noch habe.
Ich wollte da mal ein Video drüber machen, aber die haben ja alle nichts Sinnvolles geliefert.
Der Einzige, der was geliefert hat, war einer, der wusste nicht, wie man auf das erste Element in einem Array zugreift,
hat eine For-Eat-Schleife gemacht und hat die dann gebraked nach dem ersten Element, weil er das erste Element rausholen wollte.
Der war geil, Alter.
Sixhead, Alter.
Richtig massive Sixhead.
Oh Mann.
Das war wirklich weird champ.
Sowas habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Der Index gibt es nicht.
For-Eat-Break-Pattern-Beste.
So, was gucken wir uns denn heute an?
YouTube New Feature Changes Everything.
Also wenn ich eins von solchen Videos gelernt habe, ist, dass Sachen, die angeblich everything changen, eigentlich nichts changen.
Weil das einfach nur immer wichtig to a Video ist.
Big Changes.
Ja, man kann jetzt seinen Channel ordentlich benennen, wenn man nicht schon so früh dabei war und einen ordentlichen Kanallink hatte.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ganz gut, aber ich werde da nichts ändern.
Mein Name ist einprägsam, den kennen die Leute und der Channel-Link ist auch easy.
Easy as fuck.
Oh, nichts dabei hier.
Ich würde sagen, oh ne Leute, Lisp in 100 Sekunden kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Das ist mir zu heftig.
Zu viele Klammern für die Uhrzeit.
Lisp.
Meine Güte.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen.
Es gab ein Event im Battlefield 2042 und die Leute fanden es nicht gut.
Da ist geflamed.
Also für das, dass es ein Event gab, gibt es erstaunlich wenige Spieler, muss man mal sagen.
So geil war das Event anscheinend nicht.
Der Halo ist immer noch abgehangen.
Es macht New World eigentlich gerade so.
Okay, ist ein bisschen hochgegangen wieder.
Ja, ja, es gibt ein Event, es gibt irgendwie so einen Close Quarters Event oder sowas.
Also irgendwie haben sie die Maps kleiner gemacht, keine Ahnung genau.
LevelCapture Bait wird uns das bestimmt gleich erzählen.
Muss ich gerade mal was gucken.
Wo habe ich mein Handy?
Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Ich hatte glaube ich irgendein Video gespeichert, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das war nice, das
muss ich mit euch zusammen gucken.
Hab ich da irgendwas drinne?
Sword nach Newest Edit.
Ne, anscheinend doch nicht.
Wir können uns das Fireship Video zur Fleet angucken, das kenne ich noch nicht.
Nicht Fripp Ship.
Fleet, weil da hatten wir es ja gerade vorn.
8 vs. 8 Conquest of Doom, 8 vs. 8, ich dachte es wäre 16 vs. 16.
Ganz bescheuert.
Genau das Event, was angeblich dann irgendwie nur ein paar Stunden on war und dann abgeblasen
wurde, ja ganz komisch, weil, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht was Dice da macht.
LevelCapture wird uns wahrscheinlich gleich erzählen.
28 Ideen für Home Automations, Hühnerstelle, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Nichts dabei.
So, aber wir gucken uns mal kurz wirklich, wir gucken uns mal das Fleet Video einmal,
gucken was Fireship dazu sagt.
Fireship kennt sich aus.
Der wird wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwas memen und dann ist das Video vorbei.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Erzähl.
Ich, im Leben nicht, im Leben nicht, also aktuell muss es wohl ziemlich unstable sein.
Plugins, ja gut, ganz ehrlich, ich muss euch mal sagen, ich verstehe den Sinn von Fleet
nicht.
Wer mit den JetBrains Produkten was machen will, wo es jetzt schon eine fertige JetBrains
IDE gibt, also Java, C-Sharp, Python, Ruby, PAP und sowas, der nimmt doch die.
Und das eins, ich mein, die Leute können auch meintligen Webstorm nehmen, also für
was genau?
Da bleibt doch nur so Sachen wie beispielsweise Platform I.O.
Microcontroller, was gut in Visual Studio Code funktioniert, aber dafür gibt es die
Plugins nicht.
Also ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher wofür das eigentlich da sein soll.
Welche Technologie nimmt man für App-Programmierung Android?
Das hängt wie immer davon ab, was du für eine App machen willst.
Das einfachste dürfte wahrscheinlich sein, du nimmst irgendwas Webbasiertes, so Ionic
oder irgendwie sowas, dann kannst du bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich Easy iOS mit unterstützen.
Ansonsten, wenn es irgendwelche super High Performance, Flutter ist auch eine Möglichkeit,
wenn es irgendwelche super Native High Performance, Geschichten und was auch immer braucht, was
du mit den anderen Sachen nicht machen kannst, dann musst du halt eine Kotlin oder Java App
bauen.
Aber ansonsten, ich würde irgendeinen Webbasierten Kram nehmen oder Flutter.
Flutter ist auch okay, aber Flutter ist halt, was mich an Flutter ein bisschen nervt ist,
dass es halt eine eigene Sprache, ein eigenes, also ein komplett eigenes Ding ist.
Und man sich dann halt denkt, ja warum?
Also, hätte man das nicht einfach irgendwie als Aufsatz zu meinetwegen Go machen können?
Ich bin jetzt nicht der riesen Go-Fan, aber mehr Bock als auf eine eigene Sprache, nur
dafür hätte ich, wäre es mir dann schon.
Oder man hätte einfach JavaScript genommen.
Ein wenig hätte ich JavaScript nehmen sollen.
Warum es Dart sein muss, das finde ich ein bisschen Paynes-Champ, keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber Flutter geht natürlich auch.
Ich persönlich würde irgendetwas Webbasiertes nehmen, so Ionic oder React Native oder was
es da nicht alles gibt.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich mache keine Mobile Apps.
Ich habe noch nie eine richtig echte Mobile App mit App Store.
Ne, wie heißt das nicht, Zertifizierung, Akkreditierung, ne App Store, Validierung, was auch immer,
dass man es halt einreicht beim App Store.
Da habe ich noch nie gemacht, also Freigabe, ja genau.
Also habe ich, weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe natürlich ein bisschen so halbwegs schon die
ein oder anderen Sachen mir angeguckt.
Also wir erschienen diese ganzen Frontend Frameworks, also die ganzen JavaScript-Geschichten,
die man verwenden kann für Apps eigentlich am besten für einfache Sachen.
Und von all dem, was ich so ein bisschen Tutorials und sonst wie geguckt habe, muss ich sagen,
hat mich Ionic bisher am meisten angesprochen.
Ich kann es aber nicht aus der Praxis berichten, weil ich es noch nie verwendet habe.
Hat Twitch jetzt echt eine Kategorie mit Schlafen drinnen?
Ja früher wurdest du nicht unbedingt gebannt, aber es stand glaube ich in den Benutzungsbedingungen
drin, dass du irgendwie aktiv im Stream sein musst oder irgendwie sowas.
Naja, die haben festgestellt, manche Leute machen 48 Stunden Streams, pennen dabei ein,
was sollen sie machen, können sie jetzt ja schlecht bannen.
Also gibt es das Kategorie Schlafen.
Wobei ist die Kategorie Schlafen, sondern ist die Kategorie nicht irgendwie anders,
irgendwie abwesend oder sowas?
Ich habe letztens mich auch schon, genau im Only Sleeping, genau ja.
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, also warum?
Also erstens warum sich das Leute angucken, wobei ich das irgendwie schon verstehen kann,
das ist der Meme-Faktor im Chat.
Aber ich würde mich niemals, ich würde mich nicht im Schlafen streamen.
Also ich würde mich so vor der Kamera in der Regel eh nicht streamen, aber im Schlafen?
The fuck? Naja.
Ja, das ist so ein Ding, ich meine, guck mal, es gibt Leute, die sitzen am Pool und gucken
alleine 13.000 Leute, einen Streamer, Streamerin an.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht so genau, aber das sind halt so Twitch Trends.
Ich kann es insofern nachvollziehen, wenn es irgendwelche 48 Stunden Streams
oder sowas sind oder teilweise noch mehr.
Ja, da musst du halt mal kurz pennen, wenn du sinnvolle Streams machen willst.
Aber ansonsten, gucken wir mal, Twitch, I'm only sleeping.
Was haben wir denn hier? Da liegen Leute in der Ecke und pennen.
Unge pennt und macht Let's Play, Replays oder sowas.
Die schläft offensichtlich nicht.
Warum? Was ist da los, man?
Ich meine, man sieht einfach sein nicht so viel mit Haaren bedecktes Haupt von hinten,
wie er schläft, also so sieht mein Kopf von hinten auch ungefähr aus.
Keine Ahnung, Alter.
Das ist wieder so weird, Champ, man.
Es ist quasi so ein bisschen Big Brother, nur auf Twitch.
Dann du kannst die Leute 24 7 dir angucken.
Keine Ahnung, ich muss es nicht.
Ich muss nicht alles verstehen auf Twitch.
Egal, wir gucken uns jetzt das Video an.
Auf geht's Feier.
Das stimmt wohl, das stimmt wohl.
Ich meine, der einzige wirklich Kompetitor, also verbreitete,
zu VS Code war ja Atom und Atom gerade war GitHub
und GitHub ist Microsoft, genauso wie es Code und Atom ist eingestellt.
Es gab mal Prackets von Adobe, wo ich mir immer noch nicht sicher bin,
ob man die überhaupt so ausspricht nach 20 Jahren
und ob sie nicht eher Adobe heißt.
Aber es gab mal Prackets, weiß nicht, ob das irgendjemand noch kennt.
Das war eigentlich, als es rausgekommen, okay, mittlerweile ist es sogar archiv.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee war,
das so schleifen zu lassen.
Also Prackets war zum Release relativ cool.
Da konntest du live Webseiten editieren drinne.
Also dann hast du beispielsweise einen Editor gehabt
und hast dem Editor dann irgendwas an deinem HTML
und sonst wie was gerne was hast du live in der Seite gesehen.
Heutzutage musst du sowas nicht mehr in einen Editor integrieren.
Heutzutage hast du Live Reload Features
beziehungsweise Hotswappable Modules und alles Mögliche mit drinne.
Zu was wurde der jetzt zu pH Code?
Das habe ich, das kenne ich und ich wusste nicht, dass das jemand geforkt hat.
Das da? Nee, oder was? Was denn, welches?
Was ist das?
Was da?
Das ist ein Prackets Fork oder was?
Aha, naja gut, es gibt so viele Editors, man.
Also ganz im Ernst, ich bin immer noch nicht so wahnsinnig,
also immer noch nicht hundertprozentig von überzeugt, warum es jetzt wirklich
einen elektron basierter Editor werden musste, den alle verwenden.
Aber okay, das Ding funktioniert gut.
Es ist dank JavaScripten, das ist eigentlich der größte Vorteil an
Visual Studio Code im ganzen JavaScript basiert.
Es ist halt easy erweiterbar.
Es gibt glaube ich keinen Editor, der so viele gute Erweiterungen hat
wie Visual Studio Code.
Emacs hat es vor Jahrhunderten schon probiert,
einen Editor auszuliefern mit einer ordentlichen, naja,
E-Lisp ist keine ordentliche Sprache, mit Erweiterungsfunktion.
Allerdings ganz im Ernst, das stinkt halt mal komplett gegen Visual Studio Code ab
und es gibt eigentlich gar keinen wirklichen Grund mehr, Emacs zu verwenden.
Ganz im Ernst, ich verstehe. Wim verstehe ich noch.
Wim, schnell mal kurz im Terminal aufmachen, um was zu editieren
und wieder zu schließen, verstehe ich.
Aber Emacs ist, wie ist das, dead mittlerweile.
Links erlaubt zu reddit, ja, solange es kein
not safe for work Content ist.
Ist der Chain noch eigentlich immer noch gebannt
für seine komischen Links von letztem Mal?
Nee, da ist er wieder.
Da ist er ja schon wieder.
Kaum spricht man voll jemand.
Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
So, jetzt kommen wir aber in das Video endlich mal weiter, fertig.
War was mit mir? Nee, nee, schon gut, schon gut.
Wenn du es schon wieder vergessen hast, ist es nicht schlimm,
dann kommst du nicht auf die Idee, das noch mal zu machen.
Hoffentlich.
Das ist stündvoll.
Okay, wenn das paid ist, sehe ich ja noch weniger Sinn drinne,
warum man das verwenden sollte.
Also wäre das free und würde teilweise ein bisschen
der Premium Funktionalität von anderen JetBrains Ideals
quasi kostenlos mitbringen, dann würde ich ja verstehen,
dass die Leute das verwenden.
Aber, also wo soll der Sinn von sein?
Ich verstehe es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Also das letzte Mal, das letzte Mal konnte man sich
die Sachen auch noch so runterladen ohne Toolbox.
Mit Toolbox war halt einfacher.
Ja, JetBrains wurden noch mal teurer?
Oder ist das jetzt die Preiserhöhung, die sie angekündigt haben,
die die Kraft tritt?
Ja, auch richtig rein.
Guckt euch das mal an, Ben.
Ich sag doch, ich sag doch, Leute, immer.
Unbenutzter RAM ist verschenkter RAM.
Einfach dreimal Fleet starten und die 32GB sind bezahlt.
Deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht, warum brauchen die so viel RAM?
Das klingt doch eigentlich relativ effizient, oder?
Also
Deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht, warum brauchen das so viel RAM? Das klingt doch eigentlich relativ effizient, oder?
Also Kotlin, okay, das ist JVM, das ist Java Runtime, aber die Java Runtime, also
Ja, Java-Programme sind dafür berüchtigt, sinnlos RAM zu verbrauchen, aber das muss ja nicht so sein.
Nein, man muss ja nicht einstellen, schnappt ihr beim Start mal 2 GB RAM. Das geht ja auch anders.
So, und dass sie Skia benutzen, um selbst ihre Fenster zu malen, spricht jetzt auch nicht dafür, dass das super viel RAM verbrauchen müsste.
Also warum es so viel braucht, keine Ahnung. Das stimmt voll.
Massive Feature, Massive Feature, Steuerung F, da kam noch nie jemand drauf.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es wohl keine Plugins für gibt, aktuell.
Dabei gibt es eigentlich schon Svelte-Plugins für die ganzen Jetplanes-Dinger.
Das ist doch das einzige Feature, was Fleet irgendwie dazu da hervorhebt, dass man Plugins für...
Hä? Okay, ich verstehe den Sinn dieser Plattform immer noch weniger.
Natürlich, natürlich, natürlich Wim, was sonst?
So, also im Prinzip bin ich jetzt genauso schlau wie vorher, ich wüsste nicht, warum ich den Kram verwenden sollte.
Aber wir haben, wir haben wieder was gelernt.
Und sonst nix. Nee, nee, nee, Lisp, Lisp kann ich mir jetzt nicht geben. Neues Battlefield habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf. Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten? Heizung kaputt, Gehalt im Bereich Sanitär, Heizung und Klimatechnik, lohnt sich das?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber ich wäre froh, es gäbe mehr Leute, die das machen. Das heißt, es wäre schön, wenn es sich lohnt, dass es mehr Leute machen.
Der verdient so viel, wirklich? Dann müssen wir das jetzt mal angucken. Ich hoffe, dass der was verdient, weil ansonsten will der Kram ja keiner machen. Der soll ruhig ordentlich verdienen. Ich hoffe für den, dass er ordentlich Kohle kriegt.
Ganz im Ernst, es gibt Jobs, die sind sinnvoll. Sowas wie das hier. Und es gibt so viele Bullshit-Shops, wo man sich fragt, warum ist das, warum existiert das überhaupt?
Und dann soll lieber die gut verdienen.
Ja zum Beispiel überlegt euch mal, was Leute verdienen, die im C++-Cremium sitzen. Das sollten andere deutlich mehr verdienen.
So, schauen wir mal, da gucken wir uns das mal kurz an.
Das ist hier unten alles total ölig.
Angefangen habe ich mit 14 Euro die Stunde.
Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, Guns n' Roses, ToS.
Macht es aus. ToS. ToS. Ich kann das nicht abspielen wegen ToS-Musik. Was ist das?
Okay.
Hallo, ich bin der Markus. Ich bin Anlagenmechaniker für Sanitär, Heizung und Klimatechnik und arbeite da im Bereich Kundendienst.
Ich schaue jetzt erstmal nach, was wir heute überhaupt für Aufträge haben. Das geht jetzt hier los bei 7.30 Uhr Impro-Link. Na gut.
Auf geht's.
Dann leiten wir noch das Material an für heute. Das sind quasi immer unsere Materialien für den ganzen Tag, was wir heute zu machen.
Wir haben ja einmal einen Spülkasten heute. Da schaue ich nur nochmal nach, ob alles passt.
Unser erster Termin ist jetzt scheinbar eine Wartung. Da fehlt jetzt hier zum Beispiel noch eine Öldüse.
Letztendlich mache ich Kunden glücklich, weil der Kunde ruft an und dem ist halt kalt oder wie auch immer und ich komme zu ihm.
Vielleicht ist ihm auch das Gas abgestellt worden.
Hier ist eine Heizung.
Das ist jetzt hier unser Öldüsenlager. Jetzt müssen wir noch die Richtige finden.
04,60 Grad HFD. Das ist die, wo verbaut ist. Super.
Wie? Wollen die mir ernsthaft erzählen? Die haben hier mal jemand, der was arbeitet?
Die letzten paar Videos, die wir geguckt haben, wurden da ein paar Excel-Files rumgeschickt bzw. irgendwie HTML-Copypasted. Der macht tatsächlich was.
Das passt. Die Koffer rutschen hier immer ein bisschen raus.
Dann haben wir eigentlich soweit alles, oder? Spülkasten, Wartungsmaterial, Wasserhahn.
Gut. Ich sage mal zu 50% nein. Also ich weiß nicht so richtig, was auf mich zukommt.
Das kannst du im Vorfeld insofern ja auch nicht wissen, weil selbst wenn die Leute das beschreiben am Telefon,
das was die Leute dir beschreiben am Telefon, hat ja mit der Realität meistens nichts zu tun.
Uns erwartet jetzt eine Ölwartung von einer Ölheizung. Die ist jetzt auch schon länger nicht mehr gemacht worden.
Das heißt, ein bisschen Staub wird uns schon erwarten bzw. Ruß.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass das Navi irgendwie eine falsche Adresse jetzt uns anzeigt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Fran, der Streamer.
Ganz woanders hin.
Okay, da vorne ist...
So dass er kein Däne ist.
Hallo, guten Morgen. Die Ölheizung, okay.
Komm zur Wartung.
Let's go dude, genau. Alles klar.
Die Wartung ist halt wichtig, um zu überprüfen.
Erstmal funktioniert alles, weil der Kunde möchte ja auch ein Jahr ohne Störungen haben.
So, schauen wir mal.
Nach Möglichkeit hätte ich gerne mehrere Jahre ohne Störungen.
Der Keller ist mega sauber.
Mein Keller wollen die nicht sehen in so einer Sendung.
Paper please.
Erstmal sauber machen.
Das ist bestimmt wieder Tossmusik.
Egal, ich lasse es jetzt trotzdem laufen.
Was willst du machen?
Oh je, die Ölpumpe ist irgendwie auch total ölig.
Wenn schon mal irgendwo das Öl tropft, dann ist das schon mal gar kein gutes Zeichen.
Weil das soll nicht so sein.
MonkaS.
Das Öl tropft.
Also im schlimmsten Fall tauschen wir da einfach die Ölpumpe aus.
Das machen wir jetzt allerdings nicht heute.
Das kostet, aber eine neue Pumpe kostet wahrscheinlich wieder 2000 Euro oder so.
Die Anlage läuft jetzt.
Es ist halt immer schwierig dem Kunden beizubringen, wenn ein Teil defekt ist.
Und die sind dann halt auch recht teuer schnell.
Die Frage ist halt, ist man da nicht vielleicht, weil die Teuer sind, die Teile,
und je nachdem wie viel man dran verdient, ist man da vielleicht nicht relativ schnell dabei zu sagen,
ah guck mal, da hängt ein bisschen Öl dran, es muss defekt sein, lass mal austauschen.
So, wir machen natürlich eine Abgasmessung nach jeder Wartung.
Weil wir ja schauen müssen, ob die Abgaswerte passen.
Die Anlage soll ja auch nicht rusen, wenn ich die jetzt in Betrieb nehme.
War der CO2 wert.
Ich muss mal was zu meiner Heizung kurz erzählen.
Das hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mit ihm zu tun.
Nur was ich da für Erfahrung gemacht habe mit meinem Heizungswartungstyp.
Also, wir hatten öfters mal den Fehler, Moment, wie ist man, Fehler E1 oder E12?
E12?
Brenner?
D1, D1 ist es.
Störung D1.
Hatte ich total oft, ich habe eine Heizung.
Ja, stell dir mal vor, Sachen gibt es überhaupt nicht zu erwarten, dass ich eine Heizung habe.
Fehler, Brenner D1.
So, was im Prinzip darauf hindeut, dass es zu heiß wird.
Beziehungsweise, dass der Brenner irgendwelche Probleme entweder zu heiß wird.
Oder irgendwie die Gaszufuhr unterbrochen ist.
Was auch immer, der Brenner kackt ab.
Und wenn der Brenner ausgeht, durch den Fehler, dann geht er nicht von alleine wieder an.
Weil sonst könnte ja was kaputt gehen.
Nein, du musst dann runter an die Heizung und diesen Fehlerbutton drücken, zum Entsperren.
So, und ich hatte das laufend, laufend hatte ich Fehler.
Und dieser Typ von der Firma, von da wo wir die Heizung haben, der war auch ein paar Mal da.
Der hat dann einmal sauber gemacht, hat irgendwie sonst was überprüft.
Und es hat nie funktioniert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der gemacht hat.
So, und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, scheiß drauf, du guckst dir das jetzt selber mal an.
Nachdem ich keine Ahnung von Heizungen habe, habe ich erstmal auf Softwareseite geguckt.
Ja, was ist denn da eigentlich eingestellt?
Ich habe festgestellt, dass die Heizkurve,
ich zeige dir mal ein Bild, so.
Heizkurve,
also sprich bei wie viel Außentemperatur,
der wie warm das Wasser macht,
dass meine Heizkurve so eingestellt war, dass der auf über 100 Grad war, also dass er an 100 Grad war nach ein paar Minuten.
Das war quasi, meine Heizkurve war quasi wupp, wupp.
Also sprich, das Ding, der Heizer, der Brenner hat versucht, das Ding heißer zu machen als ging,
weil du musst es ja abtransportieren können.
Also sprich, das Wasser, was da hinten rumfließt, musst du ja irgendwie abtransportieren können, die Wärme vom Brenner.
Und das ging nicht. Der Brenner war dann, es wurde einfach zu heiß,
die Ente, das konnte nicht abtransportiert werden, das ist überhitzt, der Brenner hat sich ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt habe ich die Heizkurve schlicht und ergreif mal etwas runter gedreht,
so dass es eben nicht instant auf 100 Grad ist.
Und siehe da, seit drei Jahren oder so funktioniert die Heizung ohne jegliche Probleme.
Also so viel teilweise zu den Experten da, da frage ich mich auch, was ist mit euch los?
Und da bin ich mir halt immer unschlüssig, lag das bei dem da dran, dass der das nicht wusste, was er macht?
Oder hat er das absichtlich gemacht oder zumindest absichtlich so gelassen, dass er mehr Geld verdienen kann?
Das weiß man da halt immer nicht so genau.
So, weiter gucken.
Viel zu niedrig, das heißt viel zu viel Sauerstoff in der Verbrennung drinnen.
Deswegen tun wir ein bisschen Wasser in der Luftklappe noch einstellen.
Und wir wollten ja weniger Luft haben, weil wir zu wenig CO2 hatten.
So ungefähr.
Zu wenig CO2?
Das müssten wir jetzt mal Fridays for Future auf Twitter posten, dann ist es vorbei.
Schauen wir mal, wo wir jetzt mit den Werten hinkommen.
Kacke am Dampf.
Da wollten wir, dass er hier ein bisschen höher ist.
So, mal jetzt noch niedriger.
Das Ganze hat mich halt eben so stutzig gemacht, dass die Werte so komisch waren.
Und dann eben lieber noch mal den Öldruck nachgemessen.
Aha.
In dem Fall ist er jetzt viel, viel, viel, viel zu niedrig eingestellt.
Okay.
Crazy, erster Termin direkt.
Ja, normalerweise hätte ich jetzt gedacht, naja, Wartung halt.
Man geht halt hin und wartet halt einfach und dann passt es aber in dem Fall jetzt nicht.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt...
Was macht man, um den Öldruck anzuheben?
Jetzt eh noch mal ein bisschen rauf.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Okay, man dreht einfach an sowas, okay.
So, aber jetzt sind wir schon fast bei 13.
Also das passt, da brauchen wir jetzt auch nichts mehr nachstellen.
Das können wir so lassen.
Exzellent.
Siehste, sowas ist doch top.
Der macht da nicht zwei Termine draus.
Der macht da nicht sinnloses, wir tauschen jetzt was aus.
Der repariert das und jetzt funktioniert der Kram einfach wieder.
Da freut sich derjenige, dem die Heizung gehört.
Es wird wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht Unsummen kosten.
Vielleicht war er jetzt eine Stunde zu Werke oder eineinhalb Stunden.
Das wird dann am Ende wahrscheinlich irgendwie, je nachdem was er getauscht hat, wahrscheinlich kostet das irgendwie 200 Euro oder so.
Das ist dann in Ordnung.
Perfekt.
Also angefangen habe ich mit 14 Euro die Stunde.
Und das hat sich dann halt recht schnell nach oben entwickelt.
Ich kriege jetzt 23,50 Euro die Stunde.
Ja.
Wie findest du das?
Ich würde es ja gerne vergleichen mit was ich kriege.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich die Stunde kriege.
So.
Also ich habe jetzt davor noch bei der Wartung festgestellt.
Aber 23 Euro die Stunde hört sich doch ganz okay an.
Das sind dann quasi je nachdem acht Stunden am Tag.
3000 irgendwie.
Das müsste doch eigentlich ganz ordentlich sein.
Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen unlichtes oben beim Magnetventil.
Die sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch erneuern.
Ich brauche nur eine Unterschrift für die Wartung.
Dankeschön.
Perfekt.
Servus.
Also ich habe noch nie nach einer Gehaltserhöhung betteln müssen.
Mein Chef kommt immer zu mir und sagt so.
Markus, jetzt kriegst du hier nochmal mehr Gehalt.
Giga-Chat-Chef.
Ganz davon abgesehen, der Chef kann es auch nur machen, wenn es gut läuft.
Das finde ich aber auch gut, weil letztendlich, man muss ja mal eins sagen.
Also, willst du deine Mitarbeiter motivieren?
Ja, du kannst mit so komischen Zeugs anfangen wie irgendwelche Events und sowas.
Manche mögen das vielleicht geil finden, ich nicht. Ob er es geil findet, keine Ahnung.
Das einfachste, um Mitarbeiter zu motivieren, ist ihnen schlicht und ergreifend,
ohne dass sie ewig lang rumnörgeln müssen, ohne dass sie ewig lang rumnerven müssen
und tausendmal nachfragen, einfach mehr Geld geben.
Weil die gehen alle dahin arbeiten, weil sie Geld verdienen wollen.
Klar, wenn das dein Job ist, der dir auch noch Spaß macht, beziehungsweise dort,
wo du irgendeinerweise aufgehst, ist natürlich noch was zusätzliches.
Aber letztendlich gehen wir eigentlich alle arbeiten, weil wir Geld brauchen.
Team-Event im Kletterpark.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das sagst, weil ich das mal erzählt habe.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das mal erzählt habe.
Ich muss das mal kurz, wenn ich, wenn ich, erzähle ich es mal ganz kurz.
Und zwar, das glaube ich dir, Jane und das glaube ich dir natürlich sofort.
Du machst nur ehrenamtliche Jobs.
Überall umsonst.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, also Kletterpark, Kletterpark.
Also, wir hatten mal ein Projekt auf der Arbeit
und da wollte sich der Projektmanager richtig viel Mühe geben.
Und meinte dann zu uns so, und wenn das dann erfolgreich fertig ist,
beziehungsweise das war ja mehr oder weniger fertig,
wenn das dann erfolgreich fertig ist, dann gehen wir alle mal zusammen in den Kletterpark.
Und wir haben uns so angeguckt.
Was meint er das jetzt ernst?
Oder sollten wir lieber dafür sorgen, dass das Projekt nicht erfolgreich fertig wird?
Aber er meinte das so richtig als Belohnung, so nach dem Motto,
er haut jetzt hier voll einen raus, dass die Leute richtig mega motiviert rangehen.
So, yeah man, Team-Event im Kletterpark.
Endlich, da habe ich schon die ganze Zeit drauf gewartet.
Und alle so, cringe, ich will nicht in den Kletterpark.
Vor allem, was soll ich im Kletterpark, man?
Was soll ich denn da klettern?
Damals war ich noch dicker als heute.
Naja, zumindest im Endeffekt ist es dann drauf rausgelaufen,
es war erfolgreich und wir sind nicht in den Kletterpark gegangen,
sondern wir sind was essen gegangen.
Zu normalen Zeiten.
Wunderbar.
Wisst ihr was noch besser war?
Ein paar Leute haben ihn dann gefragt,
so 50% Fun, also 50% Spaß, 50% ernst gemeint,
ob das Arbeitszeit wäre, wenn man in den Kletterpark geht.
Da ist er voll ausgeflippt.
So nach dem Motto, er gibt sich so viel Mühe,
dass er sich quasi das Geld,
dass er sich das Geld vom oberen Management da irgendwie genehmigen lässt.
Und jetzt wollen die Leute das auch noch bezahlt haben,
und da war er total stinkig danach.
Ich kann es insofern verstehen,
weil er hat halt wirklich gedacht,
er macht was wahnsinnig Geiles für uns,
indem er da Geld...
Aber es will keiner in den Kletterpark von uns,
geschweige denn mit der Firma und dann mit den Leuten vom Projekt.
Was will ich im Kletterpark, man?
Ich will heim, ich will einen Stream anschmeißen,
irgendwas basteln, YouTube Zeug machen, was spielen,
hier ein bisschen wandern gehen,
ich will nicht mit der Arbeit in den Kletterpark.
Ah, man.
Könnt ihr mir ein gutes Frontend-Framework verpeilen?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist anscheinend wahrscheinlich das einzige Sinnvolle.
Oh man, das war was.
Egal, weiter, hier.
Wo ist der Heizungsman?
Waschmaschinenhahn und Licht.
Okay.
Eine dieser drei Türen wird es sein.
Alter, die Musik ist ja gut,
Leute, übertreib es halt mal.
Warum rasten die so aus mit der Musik?
Hier ist sogar ein Eimer drunter.
Warum geht nicht einfach jemand mit ihm runter
und zeigt ihm, welcher Wasserhahn das ist?
Das wäre zu einfach gewesen, oder?
Ja, ich ruf mal einen Techniker an,
und sag, mein Wasserhahn ist kaputt,
und der kommt dann vorbei,
und ich sag, geh mal in den Keller,
ich komm nicht mit, oder wie?
Natürlich würde ich mit runtergehen
und zeigen, welchem Wasserhahn es geht.
Alles klar, dann tropft der Wasserhahn.
Dann haben wir jetzt einmal die Leitung,
die wir absperren müssen.
Die Keller hier sind alles so super sauber
und geputzt und so.
Wir sind in so einem Kellerabteil drinnen,
was natürlich abgesperrt ist.
Okay, dann probieren wir unser Glück.
Dann gehen wir jetzt mal irgendwo...
Hallo, ich bin mal Abel.
Eine ganz kurze Frage.
Das Kellerabteil unten...
Der Typ, der den angerufen hat,
oder die, die den angerufen haben,
die müssen doch irgendwie...
Ich würde so irgendwie den Schlüssel geben,
oder muss doch irgend einer da sein?
Ach, du meinst,
der Hausverwalter hat angerufen,
ein Bewohner hat sich gemeldet,
und der Hausverwalter ist gar nicht da, oder wie?
So nach dem Motto, ja, gehen Sie da einfach mal vorbei
und gucken.
Das ist halt immer so random Kram.
Das kann ich auch überhaupt nicht ab.
Ja, wenn irgendwie einer
so vages Zeug erzählt,
und dann sagst du, ich guck's mir mal an,
und du findest überhaupt nicht das vor,
beziehungsweise nicht, was er eigentlich meint.
Vor dem Waschraum rechts, wissen Sie,
wem das gehört?
Erster Stock.
Ich hab doch gerade jemand gehört.
Wir müssen ja rein.
Was hilft's?
Das ist sehr unangenehm, gerade frisch nach der Ausbildung.
Bei den Amis steht dir dann einer
mit der Shotgun vor dir, wenn du da klopst.
Mittlerweile, ich mein, ich muss halt da hin.
Dann muss ich da halt klingeln.
Hallo, Entschuldigen Sie, die Störung, Firma Abele.
Es geht noch einmal ganz kurz um Ihr Kellerabteil unten.
Ich müsste da einmal rein, wegen den beiden Absperrungen.
Ich bin mitten in der Besprechung.
Muss ich jetzt vorzeigen?
Das wäre gut.
Glück gehabt.
Homeoffice.
So, ich prüfe jetzt hier quasi nur noch mal.
Ist auch wirklich kein Druck mehr da.
Weil das ist echt nicht so witzig,
wenn da jetzt das noch unter Druck stehen würde.
Sollte sich natürlich nicht mitbewegen,
jetzt wollen wir den gleich rausdrehen.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie fest der drinnen ist.
Hier, die gute...
Die gute Knirbergsrohrzange hier.
Der Klassiker.
Ich glaube, den hat jeder.
Hier, die gute...
Die Knirbergs-Kobra-Zange.
Gefühlt hat die jeder Klempner,
jeder Techniker.
Ich habe natürlich auch eine,
aber die hat jeder.
Der Hersteller nennt sich ja offiziell Knirbergs,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich kenne nur Leute, die sagen Knirbergs.
Das ist aber der Zangenschlüssel.
Nein, ich meine das untere,
nicht das obere, das da.
Das da.
Das da ist was anderes.
Nein, das ist eindeutig,
das ist eindeutsch die Kobra-Zange.
Klar ist das die Kobra-Zange.
Der hat sogar eben noch das Ding verstellen.
Wisst ihr, was ich geil finde an dem Video?
Zur Abwechslung zu den ganzen Bullshit-Shops,
die man sonst so sieht.
Man hat jetzt 7 Minuten von dem Video,
das könnt ihr euch kaum vorstellen,
der arbeitet was am Tag.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Der andere hat 8 Stunden irgendwelche HTML-Copy pastet
und Daily-Meetings gemacht
und der macht was Sinnvolles.
Ich hoffe, der kriegt das doppelte von den anderen.
So, dann sperren wir das Wasser wieder auf.
Das ist nicht der Öllappen von vorhin,
das ist ein anderes.
Die Waschmaschine funktioniert jetzt wieder.
Die Bahn ist ausgetauscht.
Dann, schöne Zeit noch.
Wieder schauen.
Hallo, ich hätte gerne einmal die Körbelwurst zum Mitnehmen, bitte.
Ich wäre jetzt schon fertig für den restlichen Tag.
2 Einsätze wäre für mich da.
Dann müsste ich heim
und mich erst mal ausruhen.
Das ist in der Regel mein Trinkgeld.
Ich sammle das immer an und gebe das so nicht aus.
Das bezahlt sich von alleine mein Essen.
Mehr oder weniger.
100 Euro, krass, Alter.
Der kommt aber mit wenig Essengeld aus.
Wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahren würde jeden Tag
und dort Mittag esse,
da bezahle ich bestimmt
10 Euro am Tag Essen.
Gut, bei uns sind ja...
Ja, doch, 10 Euro am Tag Essen.
Also, na gut.
Nice, nice.
Gut, wenn man mit so wenigen Steinen kommt.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt hier rechts.
Ich würde nicht mehr als 2 Einsätze machen.
Da wäre ich fertig für den Tag.
Da hinten, im Provio.
Hallo, ich komme wegen dem Spülkasten.
Dann würde ich einmal das Innenleben erneuern,
wenn es verkalkt ist und entkalken einmal.
Das ist jetzt das typische Problem.
In meinem Auftrag steht drinnen,
Geber Ritt, 1 Mengen Spülkasten.
Wir haben jetzt hier eine 2 Mengen Spülkasten.
Aha.
Das heißt, da passen nicht alle Teile von meinem.
Entweder ich habe jetzt Glück
und ich habe im Auto das richtige Teil
oder ich habe Pech und dann müssen wir noch mal fahren.
Dann haben wir hier noch eine 2.
Wir haben absolutes Glück.
Es ist genau der, den wir jetzt gleich brauchen.
Glück gehabt.
Müssen wir nicht noch mal losfahren.
Easy.
Hier sieht man jetzt folgendes Problem.
Wir haben hier in Weilheim sehr kalkhaltiges Wasser.
Gut, dann verkalkt das ganze Innenleben.
Deswegen tauschen wir jetzt einmal das komplette Innenleben aus.
Aha.
Was ist das?
Urin?
Ach nee, Urinsteinlöser.
Quasi so entkalkungs- und
drecklöse Essigzeug
oder was?
So was in der Richtung.
Die Säure reagiert.
Alles für lecker rein, rauskommen.
Ah, yes.
Es gibt da immer 2 Arten von Kunden.
Die einen, die sagen, um Gottes Willen, da kommt der Handwerker.
Hier muss alles aussehen wie neu.
Und dann gibt es die anderen, die sagen,
der Handwerker kommt und macht eine neue Toilette rein.
Warum soll ich die jetzt überhaupt noch putzen?
Am Anfang fand ich das ziemlich eklig.
Okay, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
MonkaS, Alter.
Da wollte ich das auch immer nicht so richtig.
Die Leute denken sich kurz bevor der Handwerker kommt,
noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ich kann mir danach immer die Hände waschen.
Jetzt machen wir den finalen Test noch für den Kunden.
Wirklich die Menge weg.
Muss ich sagen,
es gibt Sachen, die finde ich eklig.
Aber Pisse,
Scheiße, sonst was gehört nicht dazu.
Das schockt mich auch nicht wirklich.
Natürlich ist es in gewisser Weise abartig, wenn das dann stinkt.
Aber das schockt mich nicht so.
Es gibt ein paar andere Sachen, die finde ich deutlich
ekliger als das.
Ich müsste nicht
reingreifen oder so.
Aber so richtig
ekelnd tue ich mich davon nicht.
Nicht, dass ich das jeden Tag machen will.
Das geht von so einem Standards-
Toilettenpapier.
Hier noch kurz einmal den sauber.
Also was ich nicht mag,
ich spucke zum Beispiel.
Was ich richtig
eklig finde, sind die Bushaltestellen,
wo die ganzen Raucher immer auf dem Boden
gerotzt haben. Da läufst du dann an der
Bushaltestelle vorbei und du hast überall nur noch
so Spuckflecken. Das finde ich richtig
abartig. Alter, das ist so
eklig. Da würde ich bevorzugen,
das Klo sauber zu machen.
Ohje,
guter Vera-Kraftform.
Wahrscheinlich
ist das einer, wo du vorne austauschen kannst.
Aber das schaut gut aus.
Okay.
Im letzten Monat habe ich 4000...
Wenn du so guckst, haben wir ja letztens gesehen.
Leider.
Wenn du noch mal so was postest, dann gibt es wieder Ban.
Nur mal so als nebenbei angemerkt.
Netto, circa 2800 Euro.
Das schwankt bei uns.
Okay, jetzt habe ich verpasst, was er verdient.
Okay.
Im letzten Monat habe ich...
Nein, der soll das nicht noch mal posten.
The fuck? Modcheck?
Modcheck? Haben wir Mods da im Zweifelsfall?
Ja, ich glaube,
es ist da.
Also, Proto, 4535 Euro.
Das sind
mal 12.
Mal gucken, falls er nur 12, falls er 12
Gelder kriegt.
Ja, fast.
Ja, fast ist egal.
Das ist doch okay.
Ah, Moment.
Mal 12 oder mal 13?
Das ist jetzt die Frage.
Der kriegt 14, dann
ist es gut. Dann ist es gut.
Ja, das finde ich in Ordnung.
Das kann man durchgehen lassen.
4500 Euro,
Proto verdient und Netto
circa 2800 Euro.
Das schwankt bei uns. Ich meine, der Monat
hat verschieden viele Tage.
Wie viele Stunden arbeitet
pro Woche? Ich
oder er? Weiß nicht.
Ich würde sagen, der Arbeit wahrscheinlich
40 Stunden, 38 oder 40.
Weiß nicht, ob die das gesagt haben.
So, ca.
2800 Euro. Das schwankt bei uns.
Ich meine, der Monat hat verschieden viele
Tage. Das merkt man auf jeden Fall.
Ach, der kriegt quasi wirklich
den Tag?
Mit der Bereitschaft. Also umso mehr
man Bereitschaft hat, wenn man mal für einen Kollegen
einspringt oder ähnliches. Dann kriegt man
natürlich auch mehr raus.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt.
Also der Spielkasten unten
funktioniert jetzt wieder.
Wir müssen halt wissen,
das Gehalt bei wieviel Stunden.
So an sich klingt es dafür echt
in Ordnung, ja. Aber man muss halt wissen, was da noch
drumherum an Bedingungen dranhängt.
Wenn da beispielsweise
öfters mal morgendliche,
was auch immer Bereitschaftseinsätze
hat, Sachen wo er eigentlich frei hat, dann drauf
ist die Frage. Klingt aber erstmal
okay.
Schönen Tag noch, gell?
Die sollten den Leuten auch, wie gesagt, ich bin
froh, dass der eine ganze Ecke mehr
verdient als der HTML-Copypaster
vom letzten Mal.
Guck mal, der ist wirklich den ganzen Tag am
schaffen. Das ist nicht so nach dem
Motto, wir machen mal ein Daily
Meeting und dann machen wir eine Runde
Tischkicker und gehen eine Runde in die Kantine
und dann machen wir noch ein bisschen HTML-Copypaste
und ein paar Excel-Dateien verschicken.
Da ist der ganze Tag, ist der Typ am Start.
Und wahrscheinlich fünf Tage die Woche
den ganzen Tag, aber da bist du
fertig, ja.
Ich will mal einen Meistershow noch machen.
Also der Kollege von vorhin auch gerade
vom Brotzeitraum, mit dem zusammen werde ich
auf die Meisterschule gehen in ein, zwei
Jahren. So, dann sind wir fertig
soweit.
Genau, dann brauche ich hier unten die Unterschrift.
Highly sophisticated, modern
Tablet-Stellzimmer.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, gell?
Ja, heute war es ziemlich mau.
0 Euro.
Aber ja, gut, das
variiert halt immer jeden Tag.
Erst mal schön gegen die Heizung kicken,
vorausgehen. Manchmal ist es mehr,
manchmal halt auch gar nichts.
Nee, bedeutet ja nicht so viel. Ich spare das halt
einfach an und wenn ich es brauche, dann gebe ich es aus.
Dafür ist es ja da.
Für was gibst du es gerne aus?
Für Motorräder.
Kann man machen.
Ich meine,
einfach alles ausgeben, was da
ist, ist doof, aber die Taktik von ihm,
so wie es sich angehört, ist ja, quasi
er behält alles und wenn er mal was haben will,
kauft er sich was.
Warum nicht?
Wie gesagt,
mehr Geld behalten als ausgeben, ist schon mal
prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Er soll sich so geile
ETFs kaufen wie ich.
Minus 3000 Euro dieses Jahr.
So soll das machen, ja.
Toss, Toss.
Egal, ich lasse es jetzt an, ist mir egal.
Ich laber da jetzt einfach drüber ohne Pause,
damit ich jetzt kein, kein, irgendwie
Warnings, okay, ist vorbei.
Alter, wie teuer
ist die Versicherung?
Ich bezahle im Jahr, glaube ich,
wartet mal, ich bezahle im Jahr, glaube ich,
für das Auto.
Also, überlegen,
was ist das für ein Auto?
Das Auto.
Also, überlegen,
300 Euro oder so?
The fuck?
Ist Motorrad teurer, ja?
Kommt ihr da durch?
Ach, alle Versicherung.
Ach so, ach so, ach so, ja.
Ich meine, ihr seid
hier sicher im Auto.
Wow.
Alter, hört mal auf,
so viel Tossmusik zu spielen, das ist ja
Wahnsinn.
Ich mag nichts
mehr anderes machen, jeden Tag gehe ich
gerne in die Arbeit und gehe dann auf.
Ohne Mist, Leute, ich glaube,
dass es mehr Handwerkern so geht
wie ihm, als so Bullshit-Büro-Jobs-Macher.
Du hast da einfach
von morgens bis abends was zu tun
und du weißt, was du gemacht hast.
Und wenn dir so Bastel und
handwerkliche Sachen Spaß machen, machst du ja auch
was, wo du dich nicht quälen musst zu.
Auch immer glücklich nach Hause.
Mach was mit Holz, ja.
Hätte ich damals doch auf den Berater hören sollen.
Ich muss nicht aufs Geld schauen, das macht mich glücklich.
Ich kann einfach
das einkaufen, was ich einkaufen möchte.
Und ich habe es so warm, wie ich es
so warm haben möchte bei mir zu Hause.
Mir braucht man nicht zum Glücklichsein.
Exzellent.
Toss.
So, ja.
Rest bleibt übrig.
Ja, nice.
Ich finde es gut, dass der ordentlich was verdient.
Das muss es sein.
Wo Rolex.
Es ist nicht jeder happy,
als wenn er ein Rolex hat.
Kollege auf der Arbeit
und letztes gescampt.
Der sammelt irgendwie Uhren oder so, fragt mich nicht genau,
was er macht. Und als letztes eine Uhr
verkauft.
Und hat die dann verschickt,
versichert über DHL und alles.
Und
der andere
hat über PayPal bezahlt.
Und dann hat er die Uhr
losgeschickt. Und der andere
hat wahrscheinlich die Uhr rausgenommen.
Aus dem Paket. Und
dann gesagt, das Paket kam
wieder an.
Und irgendwie hat es unterwegs
keiner gewogen und gecheckt und sonst was.
Und jetzt ist das Problem, dass
PayPal sagt, ja, wir glauben dem,
dass da keine Uhr drin war.
Jetzt hat er irgendwie gerade 5000
Euro oder so, woran er nicht rankommt.
Scammed.
Gescampt.
Minus 5K.
Naja, das schaffe ich mit meinen ETFs
dieses Jahr auch noch,
wenn es so weitergeht.
Nee, der ist nicht reich, für den sind
5K wirklich ordentlich. Der hat die bestimmt
verkauft, nicht weil er die Uhr nicht
haben wollte, sondern weil er wahrscheinlich
Geld braucht. Und jetzt hat er die Uhr
weg und kein Geld.
Ich weiß nicht, wofür er Geld braucht.
Vielleicht brauche ich auch Geld für die nächste Gasrechnung
oder sowas.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie es
gewogen vor dem Abschicken. Zumindest hat er
gesagt, die wäre leer
gewesen und
keine Uhr drin. So.
Er hat es wohl mittlerweile auch
Anzeige erstattet bei der Polizei, aber
wirklich tun tut sich da auch nichts.
Wie soll man sich als Versender
davor schützen?
Kein Paypal.
Nur Überweisung.
Ich denke, wenn du
in Shop bist und da im größeren
Stil machst, nachdem dich ja vielleicht
0,1% der Leute
dann scammed, dann fällt das nicht ins
Gewicht. Du kriegst wahrscheinlich
über kurze Lange die Kohle dann trotzdem irgendwie.
Aber, wenn du halt
einmal was
verkaufst, was teures als Privatpersonal
gescampt, wird es halt kacke.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich sowas
dann mit Vorkasse
bzw. Überweisung deutlich
sinnvoller.
Guck mal, ich kriege mein eigenes Video
empfohlen. Sek, das muss ich kurz anmachen.
Schauen wir uns nicht an. Ich muss es nur laufen lassen,
weil Viewtime und so.
Noch ein eigenes Video
von mir, Viewtime.
Deine ETFs sind auch im Plus,
hast du aber Glück gehabt.
Weil, was hast du da gekauft?
Also meine sind am abkacken.
Also zumindest seit
März oder so geht es richtig
runter.
Den Tab muten nicht, das Video soll checken.
Ernsthaft?
Kann man Tabs überhaupt
muten?
Mute Side.
Aber jetzt ist die Side
gemutet.
Na egal.
Aber auf Five Head Time.
Man könnte es da drüber machen,
dann wäre es gemutet.
So, was
will uns der Typ eigentlich damit sagen?
Zeig mal her.
In der Regel,
wenn sowas so anfängt, dann brauche ich
das nicht.
Ja, kann ich mit einem 128 GB
und 256 GB
USB Stick auch. Und theoretisch kann ich
sogar einen Multi Boot USB Stick
machen, wenn ich das wirklich will. Aber das
beste ist tatsächlich, wenn man
sich einfach Netboot XYZ
mitnimmt.
Also wenn man wirklich mal was braucht, nehmt euch einfach
Netboot XYZ mit. Braucht irgendwie
nur 50 MB.
Und dann kannst du quasi
übers Netzwerk booten.
Also du kannst booten vom USB Stick
und kannst dir dann aus dem Internet das nachladen, was du
haben willst.
Oder 50k,
das ist nix.
Das ist ein Bootloader und ein bisschen
Text.
Das ist doch Werbung, oder?
Das ist Sellout.
Keck.
So, und warum
ist das jetzt besser als
Multi Boot USB Stick?
Agriffiger Name?
Ja.
Mounted ESUS, also
sprich, man kann
...
Hä?
Also,
ich hab den Sinn noch nicht so genau verstanden.
Ich mein, wenn ich booten will, kann ich einfach
Multi Boot USB Stick machen.
Und wenn ich mir irgendwie Treiber und sonst was mitbringen will,
dann muss ich das ja nicht als ISO da drauflegen.
So genau hab ich den Sinn noch nicht verstanden, wozu das da ist.
Ja, und?
Habe ich den Sinn noch nicht verstanden, wozu das da ist?
Ja und?
Ganz schön fettes, ach so ist das, das ist nicht für NVMe, das ist für so eine normale SSD, dass es auch besonders fett ist.
Das ist das ein Passwort? Ist das ein Passwortfeld da oben?
Also ganz ehrlich, ich hab genau einen USB Stick dabei, ich hab einen 32 GIG USB 2 Stick dabei, der ist uralt, reicht aber für so ziemlich alles.
Warum sollte ich, warum sollte ich, wenn ich mehrere Sachen brauche, mehr als einen USB Stick mitnehmen, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja aber ich nehm doch nicht für alles eine eigene USB Stick mit, the fuck?
Ja das Problem hat man, ja gut, okay, wenn man kein Tastatur hat, ja aber, hä? Will er Ventoy vorstellen? Nee, irgend so ein Hardware Ding, was wahrscheinlich das gleiche macht. Okay weiter.
Ich versteh das nicht.
Es ist quasi ein SSD, ein SSD Wechselrahmen mit Bootmenü, oder was?
Naja, das brauche ich nicht, ganz ehrlich finde ich komplett unsinnig, das ist mega fett das Ding, verbraucht eigentlich nur Platz und jeder 0815 USB Stick kann mehrere ISOs drauf haben, beziehungsweise mehrere Images.
Loaded, genau, wollen wir uns level, komm wir lassen uns schnell mal LevelCapture Baiten, mich interessiert davon eh nur die Hälfte, das können wir dann skippen.
Ja, hab ich mitgekriegt, LevelCapture Baiten.
Ach so hieß das.
Ja und das ist das, was wir dann wieder abgeblasen haben, weil es nicht richtig funktioniert hat, wo man sich wieder gedacht hat, DICE, was kriegt der einfach auf die Reihe?
Also wir fassen zusammen, es gab ein Event, das hat erstmal nicht funktioniert und die Leute mochten das Event nicht und ansonsten gibt es nichts Neues.
Was, warum, mit der SMG spiele ich immer wenn sonst nichts geht, warum nerft ihr einfach das was ich gerne spiele?
Ich hab nichts gegen AimAssist mit dem Controller, das funktioniert doch ohne gar nicht, solange man es nicht so übertrieben macht wie in Halo, gerade in Halo Infinite, dass du quasi auf höherem Ranking Niveau nur noch Controller Spieler hast, ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Ich hab nichts gegen AimAssist mit dem Controller, das funktioniert doch ohne gar nicht, solange man es nicht so übertrieben macht, also in Halo Infinite, dass du quasi auf höherem Ranking Niveau nur noch Controller Spieler hast, ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Das wird wahrscheinlich davon abhängig sein, wie gut das Game ankommt.
Das Game hat ja relativ viele Spiel-Modi-Wetten, von denen werden 90% einfach nicht gespielt, die Leute werden einfach weiterhin Domination oder TDM spielen.
Das Spiel hat ja relativ viele Spiel-Modi-Wetten, von denen werden 90% einfach nicht gespielt, die Leute werden einfach nur Domination oder TDM spielen.
Ich glaube, das ist geil, ja.
Wobei das ja mittlerweile richtig gut sein muss.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ein Waffenschab, das ist super.
Diese ganzen Dinge existieren doch letztendlich nur, damit man Season Passes sinnvoll füllen kann.
Gibt es jemals einen Launch, der kein Fail ist, von großen Games werden wir das wahrscheinlich nicht sehen.
Da müssen wir mal Gedanken zumachen, es gab sicherlich einige, die nicht komplett in die Hose gingen.
Warum haben die denn bei Overwatch in AimAssist entfernt, wenn man Crossplay spielt?
Wahrscheinlich weil sie unfähig sind.
Wie soll man ohne AimAssist gescheit spielen können mit eurem Controller, gerade Overwatch?
Ich habe mal Overwatch auf der Playstation gespielt, als es neu war.
Ein paar Runden bei jemandem daheim.
Da habe ich Lucio gespielt und da ist mir aufgefallen, wie unmöglich das eigentlich ist, mit dem Controller zu moveen und zu aimen und die Abilities gleichzeitig zu machen.
Das konnte ich komplett knicken.
Und noch zu aimen dabei.
Wo kehrst Need for Speed?
Alter!
Es gibt Sachen, die werde ich nie verstehen.
Das ist eins davon.
Ja, aber ich kaufe mir trotzdem keine PS5 nur dafür.
Auch kenne ich auf das Game, das ist eines der wenigen Games dieses Jahr, wo ich wirklich Bock habe darauf zu spielen, aber ich will mir keine Konsole nur für ein Game kaufen.
Sonst läuft das wieder bei der PS4, die ich nicht benutzt habe.
Okay, also diese Woche nichts wirklich Spannendes passiert.
Gut zu wissen.
Das haben wir ansonsten noch zu bieten.
Oh, das wird bestimmt grausam.
Linux ist besser als Mac OS in diesen fünf Bereichen.
Wir gucken das Video nicht, sondern wir gucken uns an.
Window-Management.
Das stimmt.
Okay, da gebe ich ihm recht.
Window-Management finde ich so eine Mac OS Paints-Champ.
Aber kommt unter Linux auch darauf an, was man verwendet.
Am besten ist natürlich i3 oder sowas.
Da gibt es nämlich gar keine Windowses standardmäßig und dann braucht man auch kein Window-Management.
Und wenn man ein Window-Management nicht braucht, ist es natürlich immer noch das beste Window-Management.
Software-Installation, das ist wohl richtig.
Hardware-Choices, ja klar.
Was hast du bei Mac für Hardware-Choices?
Zwischen dem und dem oder dem Mac?
Security und Privacy, ja.
Alter, Sponsor, guckt mal, Sponsor.
Sponsor?
Supported Channel.
Also ein Fünftel von dem Video ist quasi Support und Sponsor.
Nice.
Stonks.
So muss das machen.
Mechanische Tastaturen machen mich wahnsinnig.
Ja, kann ich verstehen, wenn man daneben sitzt.
Lisp, oh nee, Lisp.
Expansive Tech, Expansive Tech, that's actually worth it.
Okay.
Zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich solche Router schon sehe.
Die wollen mir nicht erzählen, dass es das wert ist, oder?
Dann dreh ich am Rad.
Der Carlson, Dankeschön, wir gucken mal kurz rein.
Das ist es nämlich in der Regel nicht.
Also der beste Tech, der was wert ist, ist ein ordentlicher Klo.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist Blödsinn.
Genauso wie irgendwelche Gold-Audio-Kabels und so ein Bullshit.
Okay, schieß los.
Ja.
Nein, nein, totaler Schwachsinn, Alter.
Diese Dinger, da würde ich mir lieber gescheite Access Points kaufen.
Warum soll ich einen Router kaufen mit integriertem Wifi, wenn ich mir auch gescheite Access Points kaufen kann?
Wir brauchen Router, also der Heim-Benutzer, da brauchen wir einen Router mit ordentlichen Funktionen.
Das dann, deswegen finde ich die Fritzbox an sich auch gut.
Fritzbox hat standardmäßig alles, was man daheim so braucht.
Von eine Deck-Basis-Station bis theoretisch eine Mini-NAS mit USB, wobei das richtig, richtig mies ist.
Aber gut, man, immerhin, das funktioniert.
VoIP, SIP, Telefonfunktionen, ein bisschen Smart-Home-Gedöns drin, Internetzugang, kannst du alles mitmachen.
Also deswegen finde ich die Dinger nicht schlecht.
Sowas würde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Und wenn das WLAN daran nicht ausreicht, da kaufe ich mir ein paar gescheite Access Points.
Ein paar gescheite Access Points.
Und...
Ich zumindest kein Unify mehr.
So sieht's aus, da hat er recht.
Ja, ach nee.
Ja, das sage ich seit Jahren schon, dass das Multifunktionsgeräte sind.
Warum kein Unify? Weil Unify ein paar Features schleifen lässt, die ich gerne hätte.
Zum Beispiel eigene Zugangspasswörter für bestimmte Geräte.
So ziemlich jeder andere Hersteller kann es mittlerweile, im etwas höherpreisigen Segment.
Jeder Hersteller kann es.
Unify hat keinen Bock drauf.
Und auch ein paar andere Sachen, wobei ich da jetzt aus dem Steg greife, nachdem ich die Kram schon seit einer Weile rausgeschmissen habe.
Ja, dass man einen Controller braucht, finde ich auch doof. Ganz ehrlich.
Gerade wenn man nur eins, zwei, vielleicht drei Access Points daheim hat.
Also bei einem ist es halt doof, dass du einen Access Point und einen Controller brauchst.
Klar, man kann die App verwenden, aber letztendlich App ist auch doof.
Hardware-Scheiße. Na ja, die Unify-Hardware ist nicht scheiße.
Die Unify-Hardware ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend jetzt auch nichts besonderes.
Kannst dir mal so einen Access Point aufmachen.
Da ist nichts großartig abgeschirmt oder sonst was.
Das ist in Ordnung, ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das so die krasse High-End-Engineering-Geschichte bei den Unify-Dingern.
Also ich bin da nicht so der Fan von.
Also was ich jetzt benutze aktuell als Wi-Fi-Alternative,
ich habe mir auf Ebay ein paar Ruckus, Access Ruckus, Access Points gekauft.
Ich habe ein R710 und einen R510 glaube ich, einen 510 habe ich im Keller.
Den 710 habe ich oben hängen im Wohnzimmer.
Da muss man gucken, dass es die etwas günstiger gibt, weil aktuell ist das ziemlich teuer.
Neu kosten die halt 1000 Euro.
Es ist halt kein Vergleich zu Unify preislich in dem Sinn.
Man kriegt die aber teilweise schon für um die 180 Euro, dann ist das in Ordnung.
Muss man mal schauen.
Also das finde ich ist somit das beste, wenn man Features braucht, was man sich holen kann.
Leider nur gebraucht und dementsprechend nicht die aller, aller neuste WLAN-Generation.
Also man kann mit den Dingern maximal glaube ich, ja, guck mal neu 1300 Euro, Keck.
Man kann damit quasi AC machen und nicht AX, was aber jetzt nicht wirklich wild ist für daheim.
Also du kannst nur Wi-Fi 5 und nicht Wi-Fi 6 machen.
Ist jetzt aber nicht wirklich ein großartiges Problem,
weil das von der Qualität her ist, also was zählt letztendlich.
Was brauche ich in Wi-Fi 6, wenn ich mit Wi-Fi 5 oder ordentlichem, ordentlichen Access Point schneller bin.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel haben die auch so eine proprietäre Ausrichtstechnologie drinne,
was es jetzt teilweise glaube ich mit Wi-Fi 6e in anderen Geräten auch schon gibt, aber nicht so gut.
Die können beispielsweise die WLAN-Antennen, die die Polarisierung ausrichten auf das Gerät,
was quasi gerade kommuniziert, was ziemlich cool ist von der Technik.
Also ich habe seitdem ich die Dinger habe, überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Gesammtes Haus, gesamter Hof bis zum Garteneingang und auf der anderen Seite bis auf die Straße,
alles quasi mit diesem R710 abgedeckt.
Nur für den Keller habe ich noch einen kleineren gebraucht,
weil da hat es manchmal Probleme, dass die Geräte was verloren haben,
aber das muss auch durch eine ziemlich dicke Decke durch.
Und ansonsten letztendlich, man braucht auch gar keinen extra Access Point,
wenn man zufrieden ist mit dem, was eine Fritzbox oder sowas liefert.
Nö. Das ist ja, guck mal, was für Stadien gut funktioniert, kann ja für daheim nicht schlecht sein.
Und gebraucht sind die Preise nicht ungefähr auf dem gleichen Niveau wie Unify-Geräte
und für meinen Geschmack besser, gerade weil du mit Unleashed keinen Controller brauchst
und weil du für IoT-Geräte das beste Feature überhaupt hast, extra Passwörter pro Gerät.
Das ist das, wo Unify sich seit Jahren davor drückt und keinen Bock hat.
Alle anderen können es mittlerweile.
Unify hat keinen Bock darauf. Ubiquiti hat keinen Bock, das einzubauen.
Die denken sich einfach piss dich alle, keinen Bock drauf.
Also sprich, normalerweise hast du ja WLAN-technisch zwei Sachen zur Auswahl,
nur mal um das mal etwas näher auszuführen, was ich meine.
Du hast entweder stinknormales 802.11, frag mich nicht, wie es heißt, mit einem WLAN und einem Passwort dazu.
Also du hast eine WLAN-SSID und einen Pre-Shared-Key, also quasi das, was normalerweise unter WLAN-Passwort läuft.
Du klickst also quasi im Handy das WLAN an, gibst dann dein 32-stelliges Passwort ein und dann bist du im WLAN.
Dann gibt es als zweites noch WPA-Enterprise.
Das geht hintenrum über irgendeinen Authentifizierungs-Server.
Und da kannst du dann verschiedene User unterstützen, an sich eine coole Geschichte.
Das muss aber das Endgerät unterstützen.
Also sprich, wenn ihr ein Endgerät habt wie ein iPhone oder so, dann geht das.
Es ist natürlich im Setup ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber wenn ihr IoT-Geräte habt, sei es irgendwie die Klübirne, bei Klübirne ist es ja nicht,
die Lampe mit WiFi-Controller drinnen oder eine Steckdose oder was auch immer,
die können so gut wie alle kein WPA-Enterprise.
Und jetzt hast du halt das Problem, wie kriegst du es hin, dass deine Lampe mit WiFi einen eigenen Zugang bekommt in das WLAN
und nicht das normale WLAN-Passwort verwenden muss.
Was ist denn der Nachteil, wenn man das normale WLAN-Passwort verwendet?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt irgendwie einen Micro-Controller und bleiben wir bei der Lampe.
Die Lampe meldet ihr bei euch im WLAN an.
In der Lampe ist euer Passwort drinnen.
Die Lampe geht kaputt, ihr schmeißt die Lampe weg.
Jetzt könnte theoretisch jemand die Lampe, wird nicht passieren, aber nur um das Szenario zu beschreiben.
Holt sich jemand die Lampe raus und liest das WLAN-Passwort aus und schon kann es sich bei euch im WLAN einloggen.
Wenn ihr es jetzt so macht, dass die Lampe ein eigenes Passwort bekommt, wenn das euer WLAN-Zeug unterstützt,
dann löscht ihr es einfach, nachdem ihr die Lampe weggeschmissen habt und alles ist gut.
Und diese Sache mit eigenem Passwort pro Gerät, das können mittlerweile alle etwas besseren Hersteller in mehr oder weniger guter Ausprägung.
Unify hat aber gar keinen Bock das zu machen.
Es haben alle ein paar Problemchen bei, aber es können alle irgendwie.
Aber Unify hat sich gedacht, nö, das wollen wir erst gar nicht haben.
Und das, obwohl die eigentlich im Heimbereich, im Amateur-Heim-Semi-Pro-Bereich gut Fuß gefasst haben.
Und gerade da wäre das ein richtig gutes Feature.
Weil viele Leute haben eben gerade auch was mit Heimautomatisierung am Hut haben, die haben Unify.
Und gerade das Unify, das nicht unterstützt, finde ich einfach richtig mies.
Was? Nein. Quatsch. Wie willst du dir das selbst bauen?
Das ist ein Feature, was dein Access-Point können muss. Wie willst du das denn selbst bauen?
Was du selbst bauen kannst, ist irgendwelche Captive-Portal-Geschichten mit
Gehe in das WLAN rein und danach schalte dich frei im Browser und sowas mit einem Browser-Dings.
Und dann über die Mac und so. Ja, das ist richtig mies.
Aber logg dich mal von einem IoT-Gerät auf einem Browser ein.
Und selbst dann ist das rein Mac-basiert.
Ne, ne, ne. Das ist schon...
Das ist ein gutes Feature.
Leider kann es Unify nicht.
Endlich mal einer, der ist Secret.
Endlich mal einer, der ist Secrets Revealed hier.
OpenWRT kann es mittlerweile auch.
Also man kann billige TP-Link-Router, OpenWRT flaschen und das damit benutzen.
Das ist easy mit device-spezifischem Passwort, wenn es dein WLAN-Equipment kann.
Unify kann es halt nicht.
Aber selbst für Gäste-Geräte ist das teilweise gar nicht blöd.
Stell euch mal vor, ab und zu kommt jemand vorbei.
Ihr drückt dem einfachen QR-Code aus.
Der scannt den QR-Code, kommt rein mit seinem spezifischen Passwort.
Und wenn er wieder weg ist, wird das einfach wieder gelöscht und es läuft ab.
Ohne, dass man irgendwas machen muss.
Ja, das ist aber sehr durch die Brust ins Auge.
Dann müsstest du quasi, damit das funktioniert, brauchst du ein offenes WLAN.
Dann muss der sich in irgendeiner Art und Weise im Browser authentifizieren.
Und dann musst du WireGuard installiert haben auf deinem Handy,
dass du dich bei VPN ins eigentliche Netz verbinden kannst.
Bringt dir für IoT-Geräte gerade mal gar nichts.
Auf denen kannst du kein Browser aufmachen und auf denen kannst du kein WireGuard laufen lassen.
Ja, du kannst Client-Isolation machen.
Das bringt dir aber nichts, weil das WLAN-Passwort immer noch das gleiche ist.
Ein WLAN-Passwort für alle.
Naja, bin ich mal gespannt. Die letzten paar Jahre hat sich da nicht viel getan.
Das wäre gut, wenn das kommt, weil das gerade ein Feature ist für Leute,
die IoT-Sachen und Heimautomatisierung machen.
Und gerade die haben halt viel UniFi-Zeug aus Gründen,
weil es ja überall empfohlen wird.
Für die wäre das gut.
Also da müsste ich jetzt nicht wieder das einfach machen,
weil das Endgerät nichts unterstützen muss.
Da müsstest du, du könntest den WLAN aufmachen auf deinem Raspberry Pi, ja.
Und dort das einrichten, das geht auch.
Aber da musst du dich ja komplett selbst darum kümmern.
Und das WLAN auf dem Raspberry Pi ist halt Schrott versus ein ordentlicher Access-Point.
Das WLAN-Kabel in Form eines QR-Codes.
So, weiter.
Next, muss überstehen geblieben.
Ah, zu viel Zeug.
Ja.
Für IoT, also man kann sich UniFi-Zeug kaufen.
Das ist nicht schlecht, das ist preisleistungsmäßig auch durchaus okay.
Kann man jetzt, das muss man ja auch nochmal betonen jetzt.
Aber gerade wenn man Heimautomatisierung und viele IoT-Geräte hat,
dann ist es nix.
Gerade durch diesen Mangel dieses Features.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gegangen sind.
Wenn man einfach nur ordentliche WLAN-Abdeckung im Haus haben will
und die Fritzbox alleine eben nicht reicht,
um noch auf die Terrasse zu kommen und sowas.
Hey, es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen,
sich zwei UniFi-Access-Points hinzustellen.
Auf der anderen Seite würden es wahrscheinlich auch so gut
wie alle anderen billig TP-Link-Access-Points tun.
Weil die Features, die es zusätzlich in UniFi gibt,
die brauchen diese Leute nicht, die sich nur dafür kaufen.
Und alle anderen, die ein bisschen mehr machen wollen,
denen fehlen dann beispielsweise sowas wie
dynamische WLAN-Passwörter.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe nicht, warum so viele Leute
krass auf UniFi abfahren.
Ich hatte ja auch welche hier,
aber wie gesagt, mittlerweile ist alles rausgeflogen.
Übrigens, das Omada-Zeug
Das ist das TP-Link-Zeug, weil ich es hier gerade sehe.
Das TP-Link-Zeug kann das auch.
Also, die haben das mittlerweile auch drinne,
dynamische Pre-Shared-Keys.
Sogar TP-Link-Zeug kann das.
Rukus-Zeug ist unbezahlbar teuer, das ist richtig.
Ich habe mir das ja auch nur gekauft,
weil du die ältere Generation günstig auf eBay bekommst
ab und zu mal bekommst.
Also, ich habe mir einen R710 gekauft und einen R510 für einen Keller.
Das hat mich zusammen ungefähr
380 Euro gekostet.
In dem Dreh.
Das ist ungefähr der Preis, den ich auch für zwei ordentliche UniFi
ein bisschen mehr bezahlen würde.
50-60 Euro mehr.
Aber dafür geht es einfach.
Aber es interessiert mich, ob ich Wi-Fi 6 habe,
wenn ich super stabiles, komplett auf dem gesamten Grundstück
benutzbares Wi-Fi 5 habe.
Es ist ja nicht so, als bräuchte ich den Speed
irgendwie mobile von Wi-Fi 6.
Und die anderen Sachen, die funktionieren einfach.
Da kaufe ich mir lieber in 3, 4 Jahren
dann die AX-Generation sollte mir das mal...
Also, die Wi-Fi 6-Generation von denen sollte es mal günstiger werden.
Neu kaufen kannst du tatsächlich komplett vergessen.
Neu kostet der Kram über 1000 Euro pro Access Point.
Das kann man natürlich vergessen.
Du hast noch einen Exploit auf dem TP-Link-Switch.
Wie kannst du einen Exploit auf dem TP-Link-Switch geben?
Der TP-Link-Switch ist... Die meisten TP-Link-Switch sind billige,
unmanagte Dinger ohne irgendwelche
Magic drauf. Wie kann man da...
Was kann man da groß exploiten?
Energy-Switch, ja.
Das Gute, was ich halt auch an diesen ganzen
Ruckus, Ruckus...
Access Points finde, ist, dass du keinen Controller brauchst.
Du kannst die flaschen. Also, du kannst die entweder
Managed...
Okay, aber von einem Spanning Tree Exploit habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Dass du irgendwie...
Was auch immer, den Switch dir das Admin-Passwort
resetten kannst über
Spanning Tree...
Exploits? Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört, dass sowas gibt.
Alle Switche haben eine CPU drauf.
Beziehungsweise nicht unbedingt so eine klassische
All-Purpose-CPU, sondern meistens
irgendwas auf Switching spezialisiert ist. Aber die, die
haben über Managed-Interfaces, klar, die haben eine ganz normale CPU drauf.
Und da läuft dann auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ein Betriebssystem drauf. Da kannst du auch was exploiten.
Aber bei so einem ganzen dummen...
dummen Unmanaged-Switch, ja, da ist auch eine CPU drauf.
Aber ich wüsste nicht, was man da groß exploiten kann.
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, genau, diese Dinger kannst du entweder
laufen lassen mit einem Controller. Das nennt sich
Smart Zone bei denen. Ist ein bisschen sowas wie der Unify-Controller
nur besser. Oder du kannst an Leash drauf flashen.
Das ist eine Firmware, die ohne Controller funktioniert.
Da übernimmt dann einer der Access Points quasi die
Controller-Funktion. Merkste aber eigentlich nichts von.
Wunderbar ist das.
Also, da gebe ich Ihnen aber recht. Ordentlicher Access Point,
wenn der Router nicht ausreicht vom WLAN, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber jetzt sehen,
einfach den Access Point hinstellen, weil man denkt,
Fritzbox hat aber schlechtes WLAN, so wie das manche Noobs
erzählen. Solange man eine ordentliche Verbindung hat
und einen ordentlichen Empfang hat, dann ist das WLAN
von der Fritzbox auch nicht zwangsläufig schlechter,
nur weil es von der Fritzbox kommt, als von einem Dedicated Access Point.
Und von der Reichweite
her ist das wahrscheinlich so viel besser auch nicht.
Da musst du halt höchstens zwei Stück hinstellen,
was du bei der Fritzbox nicht machen kannst. In der Regel
für eine einfache Wohnung reicht das WLAN
von einer Fritzbox vollkommen aus.
Das sind die paar Quadratmeter,
alles auf einer Ebene ohne dicke Wände dazwischen,
ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Der Vorteil von mehreren Access Points ist,
dass du einen Access Point zum Beispiel
in ersten Stock auf die linke Seite stellen kannst
oder ins Erdgeschoss auf die rechte Seite vom Haus stellen kannst.
So hast du quasi im vorderen Hälfte plus Straße
hast du WLAN und hinten auf der Gartenterrasse hast du noch WLAN.
Das kannst du machen, das kannst du mit einem Gerät
logischerweise nicht machen.
Also...
Also
Leute, die dann irgendwie Verbindungsprobleme haben
und direkt neben dem Access Point sitzen, die haben wahrscheinlich
Verbindungsprobleme. Das liegt da nicht am Access Point.
Ja, das kann schon sein, das hast du recht, ja klar,
aber da würdest du dir wahrscheinlich den anderen Access Point auch nicht so viel bringen.
Dann bräuchst du höchstbräuchtest einen anderen Access Point
an anderer Position. Das wird wiederum was bringen,
aber einfach den Access Point an der Stelle, wo er jetzt steht, auszutauschen,
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so viel bringen.
Je nachdem, was es ist, das kann schon was bringen,
aber in der Regel würde ich sagen, bringt das jetzt auch nicht.
Nur weil du jetzt an die gleiche Stelle einen teureren
Access Point hinstellst.
Warum sind diese Mesh-Dinger angeblich so gut?
Ich meine, das sind doch quasi nur Repeater.
Äh, nee.
Boah, ich hab mich da vor einer Weile mal ein bisschen mit beschäftigt.
Nee, nee, nee, das war irgendwie anders.
Also, die meisten Mesh-Access-Points
kannst du ja untereinander verbinden
über Kabel. Die UniFi-Dinger
haben das ja eingebaut. Du kannst dann quasi zwischen
deinen UniFi-Access-Points quasi rohmen,
ohne dass die Verbindung abbricht,
weil die Access-Points untereinander reden und quasi das so,
wie heißt das, so Hand-Off machen mit dem Client.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Mesh-WLAN baust,
quasi zwischen mehreren Access-Points, dann weiß ich tatsächlich nicht,
was der Vorteil gegenüber einem Repeater sein soll.
Ähm, ja. In dem Fall ja,
wobei man halt sagen muss,
Repeater ist immer so ein Ding,
das darfst du dann keine super
Performance mehr erwarten. Ja, weil der Repeater
muss ja quasi die Sachen auf der gleichen Frequenz
empfangen und senden, mehr oder weniger
gleichzeitig.
Was in der Theorie zumindest bedeutet,
dass du weniger Bandbreite
zur Verfügung hast dann. Das ist übrigens
bei Access-Points über Mesh verbunden
auch nicht unbedingt der Fall. Die können ihre Inter-Access-Point-
Kommunikation ja über andere Channels machen oder über andere
Frequenzen machen als dann die kleinen Kommunikationen.
Aber ich bin kein großer WLAN-Kenner, muss ich sagen. Kann auch sein,
dass alles Stuss ist, was ich erzähle.
Also das würde was bringen, ja. Das würde was bringen,
wenn du wirklich so schlechten Empfang im Schlafzimmer hast,
dass du irgendeinen Repeater im Flur einstecken kannst.
Und das würde
was bringen, ja. Das kannst du schon machen.
Man muss halt sagen, bei denen ist es so, da tut es tatsächlich
manchmal einer, weil die eben diese automatische
Polarisierungstechnik drin haben. So quasi,
die können die WLAN-Antennen
auf das Gerät ausrichten,
was gerade was bekommen soll.
Stimmt nicht so ganz, weil die Antennen bewegen sich
ja da drinnen nicht. Aber das ist eine gute
Technik von denen. Das bisschen, was in der Richtung, gibt es
ja mit Wi-Fi 6 jetzt auch für alle.
Ja, so in der Richtung, genau.
Die können nämlich ihre Kommunikation auf anderer Frequenz machen
wie mit den kleinen und dann hast du nicht das Problem wie mit
normalen Repeatern.
Das ist dann so der beste Build für Low-Power-Server mit möglichst viel Leistung.
Ganz ehrlich, so ein fertiger HP Microserver
ist gar nicht mal so schlecht. Der Verbrauch Eidl
weniger als das
und er kommt natürlich drauf an, wie viele Festplatten du reinschmeißt und alles.
Und hat ordentlich Wumms.
Ist halt nicht mehr der neueste, ist aber durchaus okay.
Selbstbauen ist ein bisschen billiger.
Da musst du ja halt was überlegen.
Ich finde dann, also wenn es wirklich
Low-Power sein soll und ganz wenig verbrauchen soll,
dann nimm irgendwie so einen ITX. Nimm
so einen Low-Power-Intel-Plattform.
Irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das ist jetzt zwar nicht die schnellste CPU, reicht aber
für so nahezu alles aus. Du hast Data-Anschlüsse, du hast USB und PC
Express. Das ist wirklich eine gute Low-Power-Plattform.
Vielleicht gibt es aber mittlerweile auch schon ein bisschen was Neues.
Was ist eigentlich hier mit dem...
mit der SROC-Seite los?
Ne, die O-Troll-Dinger würde ich nicht nehmen, weil das ist kein
X86. Dann hast du dann andere
Probleme. Oder ist das die
X86-Kiste? Ah ja.
Der ist doof. Der ist doof. Der ist doof, weil
Cookie liegt. O-M-G.
Der ist doof, weil der ist kein Standard-Formfaktor.
Da kriegste kein gescheites Gehäuse für.
Was postet der Chat hier?
Was ist das für ein Ding? Sekunde.
Muss ich mir jetzt mal kurz angucken.
PC Maker Top Ton?
Das ist das... das erscheint mir tatsächlich eine ganz gute
Plattform zu sein, ja.
Klingt erstmal nicht verkehrt.
Die CPU?
Ne, es soll ja Low-Power sein.
CPU ist okay für Low-Power-Kram.
Also so eine aufgelötete Onboard-CPU.
Aber für Low-Power-Kram, man kann jetzt ja keine
Performance-Wunde erwarten, aber ich find die durchaus in Ordnung.
4x2,5. Das ist wirklich keine üble
Plattform, muss ich sagen. Find ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Wo gibt's das?
Was kostet das?
Das sieht auf den ersten Blick, finde ich mal ganz sinnvoll aus.
Hast du PC-Express? Aha, kein PC-Express.
Das ist für mich schon mal ein Nachteil.
Also kein 10 Gigabit.
Dann hätten sie lieber auf die ganzen 2,5 Gig
verzichten sollen.
470 Euro, das ist zu teuer.
Das ist zu teuer.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Das muss unter 100 Euro kosten, dass sich das lohnt.
Oder sagen wir um die Hunde. Ne, das ist zu teuer.
Die anderen kosten unter 100 Euro.
Dann ist es gut, das ist zu teuer.
Das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht. Also wenn ich 470 Euro ausgeben würde,
dann könnte ich mal was Gescheites kaufen.
Ne, also das ist zu teuer.
Das ist nicht sonderlich dolle, weil auch kein PC-Express
und Dover Formfaktor
passt nirgendswo rein.
How I set my boot-Video to Shrek. Ok.
Ok.
Na dann, wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat.
210 bei AliExpress
ist trotzdem noch ganz schön teuer.
Ja, aber das ist dann wieder im Bereich, das ist dann vielleicht in Ordnung.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir gucken jetzt mal das eine Video endlich mal fertig.
So, kommen wir gar nicht bei.
Wo sind wir eigentlich gerade?
Ich hab vergessen. Ah ja, bei Wi-Fi.
Ok, auf.
Ey, die haben auch angefragt bei mir, Ugreen.
Ugreen wollte auch ein Video sponsoren bei mir.
Leider sind wir uns nicht einig geworden, was es kostet.
Die wollten, dass ich irgendwie, es kann sein, dass die genau das Gleiche wollten,
dass ich diesen komischen Charger vorstelle.
Die wollten aber am Ende,
also wir sind uns nicht einig geworden für das, was ist
Money, ja.
Ich muss ja auch nicht alles machen.
Ok, weiter.
Wie? Na super.
Geil, sie sagen, man soll nicht ein scheiß Headset kaufen, nice.
Beste Headset ist immer noch das Bayer Dynamics MMX300.
Da gibt's nix.
Das stimmt wohl.
Was ist denn das andere?
Auf, schieß los.
Nein, nicht wirklich, oder?
Smarte Steckdosen. Ganz ehrlich,
theoretisch kannst du damit Strom sparen, ja.
Die meisten und wahrscheinlich 99% der Leute werden
ewig brauchen, bis sie den Anschaffungspreis dieser
Dinger wieder drin haben durch den gesparten Strom.
Das ist natürlich sinnvoll, wobei ich ganz ehrlich
nicht verstehe, dass das immer so zum Strom sparen
angepriesen wird.
Wenn man jetzt einen Heizlüfter hätte mit 200 Watt,
der den ganzen Tag boostet,
und den vergisst man immer auszuschalten und anstatt
8 Stunden am Tag läuft er dann irgendwie nur noch
eine halbe Stunde, ja, dann würde man das relativ
schnell wieder reinbekommen. Aber meistens dreht sich
ja um irgendwelche kleinen Dinger, die sicherlich
zu viel Strom verbrauchen, die sie nicht müssten,
aber die 40, 50 Euro, was sich so der 0815 Noob kauft,
der flecht sich ja keine China-Chinesen-Steckdose
selbst mit Tasmutter, als Smart Plug
rechnet sich so gut wie nie.
Wenn man so einen speziellen Anwendungsfall hat,
ja, aber die meisten Leute schließen dann da ihren
Fernseh dran an oder so, ja super, da sparst du dann
5 Watt Eidl oder so,
und die übrigens gar nicht mehr eigentlich so viel
verbrauchen dürften.
Also rein zum Geld sparen, ja, natürlich ist das
theoretisch möglich, praktisch wird das bei den
meisten nicht hinhauen.
Ja, das Ding braucht nicht so viel, ne, ne.
Bei den meisten ist hier irgendein Low-Power.
Also früher hatten die Dinger alle einen ESP-286,
was dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 150 mA, 5 Volt,
also irgendwie,
Ahnung,
0,3 Watt oder so braucht.
So, was können wir noch hier uns angucken?
Building an efficient, power-efficient Home-Server.
Wolfgang wieder am Start, der war hier sogar mal im
Stream, wo wir ein Video von ihm geguckt haben.
Mal gucken, was hier,
was er erzählt,
wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Das 19 Minuten, da müssen wir ein bisschen
vorskippen.
Also, why care about power of efficiency?
Ja, einfach weil es Geld kostet und so aktuell
mehr Geld als jemals zuvor.
Also, was haben wir denn für Empfehlungen?
Zeige mal her.
Plattform.
Also, wie gesagt, ich finde die Low-Power-Intel-Geschichten
gar nicht verkehrt, solange sie um 100 oder unter 100 Euro
kosten, ansonsten ist es einfach preisleistungsmäßig,
das nicht, nicht wert.
Ohne 16 Ampere Smart Plug.
Das mag bei den meisten, ich glaube, bei den Sonoff-Dingern,
ich meine, das mag da draufstehen, ob ich da wirklich
16 Ampere drüber laufen lassen möchte.
Das ist ja das Maximale, was aus so einer Steckdose
rauskommen kann.
Und die meisten Steckdosen
sind ja auch schon nicht für Dauerbetrieb mit 16 Ampere ausgelegt.
Was hast du denn da dran, was tatsächlich,
Heizlüfter oder
Was anderes fällt mir da jetzt gar nicht großartig ein.
Bügeleisen, Heizlüfter oder
oder was ist das?
Waschmaschinen und Trockner, ja.
Also, ich glaube, die Sonoff-Dinger sind da
theoretisch für steht drauf, aber keine Ahnung,
ob man das dauerhaft machen sollte.
Wie gesagt, die meisten Steckdosen sind schon nicht
dafür gedacht.
Genau, die meisten sind eigentlich, wenn es nicht eine
spezielle Steckdose sind, für 10 Ampere ausgelegt.
Also keine Ahnung.
Also meine Außensteckdose ist angeblich für 16 Ampere
ausgelegt.
Weil Elektrogrill und sowas, aber
sogar als ich mein Auto darüber geladen habe, habe ich es
limitiert auf 10 Ampere. Wollte das einfach nicht
8 Stunden da dran
mit voller Pulle laufen lassen.
Also, lass mal kurz gucken.
Hey, das sieht aus wie so ein S-Rock-Rack-Ding.
Ist es das?
Das stimmt wohl.
Richtig, ja.
Es gibt so viele Leute, die dir erzählen, kauf dir auf eBay
einen alten HP oder Dell-Server.
Und die, die dort preislich erschwinglich sind, die sind
wirklich richtig alt.
Die sind nicht nur laut, die sind nicht nur schwer.
Die sind auch vor allem stromhungrig as fuck.
Okay, was wird denn empfohlen?
Na gut, die 490 ist ja, glaube ich, da jetzt gerade ein
besseres Beispiel kann man da gerade nicht finden.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Was wird denn empfohlen?
Gut, also wenn du super
krasse Performance brauchst, ja, kann man sowas
reinstecken, Home-Server packen, aber weiß nicht.
Was wird denn empfohlen?
Zeig mal her.
Hier.
Ja, genau.
Die guten Oktur-Lüfter.
Was empfiehlt der denn für eine CPU?
Ist das Computerlux? Nee.
Ah, nee, Hardwarelux, nicht Computerlux, ja.
Das sieht auch seit 20 Jahren genau so aus, die Webseite,
Alter, sofort wiedererkannt.
Ja, sehe ich auch, so low power, so ein Teil hier reicht
wahrscheinlich wirklich für die meisten aus.
Aber das ist gut, das ist da so eine...
Zeig mal, was ist denn, was ist denn most power-efficient?
Okay, okay, hier haben wir gar keinen Computerlux.
Next, was wollen wir dann haben?
Ja gut, die all-in-atom-Dinger,
damit reißt die ja wirklich auch nichts,
keinen mehr vorm Hocker, ja.
Ich skippe mal kurz.
Okay, was haben wir ansonsten?
Efficient Motherboards.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich finde, wie gesagt,
die sind gut hier, das da.
Solche Teile, die sind tatsächlich ganz in Ordnung.
Das ist low power Intel, das ist das Mainboard plus CPU.
Und das kriegst du idle runter auf unter 10 Watt.
Also ich habe ja auch so ein Ding hier am Start gehabt
eine ganze Weile.
Mit Power Top und den ganzen Savings an bin ich bei 7,5 Watt gewesen.
Ich habe eben gebootet in Zustand, das bedeutet,
mit einer SSD dran und dem Mainboard mit der Onboard-CPU.
Kannste nix sagen, uneingesteckt im Gigabit Ethernet, ja.
Es ist nicht der Leistungskracher, aber in der Regel reicht es
für fast alles, was die Leute daheim machen wollen.
Die meisten Leute basteln ansonsten mit dem Raspberry Pi daheim rum.
Und mehr Wumms als ein Raspberry Pi hat's.
Zumal das X86 ist und prinzipiell auch easy,
ohne dir Gedanken machen zu müssen, alles drauf laufen lassen kannst.
5,8 Watt von der Wand.
Ich hatte schon eine CPU-Handy,
also fing ich an, Skylake Motherboards von Fujitsu zu schauen
und fand diese D340.
Power Supply.
Ja, ich hatte mir mal so einen Seasonic Platinum-Rated,
ne, Titanium-Rated oder so, glaube ich,
so richtig fettes, teures gekauft.
Das wollte ich eigentlich für den nächsten Rechner hier verwenden,
weil es aktuell nur rumgammelt.
Aber wenn ich mir den Verbrauch angucke von so einer 4090,
dann wird es mit dem 650-Watt-Netzteil wahrscheinlich nix.
Hat das Hardware-Encoding, ja, Hardware-Encoding und Decoding
die üblichen Sachen?
Also H2,6,4 und Zeug.
Ja, so ein Ding habe ich auch drin gehabt in der letzten Kiste,
die ich selbst gebaut habe.
Genau.
Genau so ein Ding hatte ich auch am Start.
Ich weiß nur, dass die mit dem roten irgendeine Nachteile hatten,
deswegen hatte ich immer die mit dem gelben Stecker.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache, Hauptsache in dem REC-Formfaktor dieses Ding drinne.
Alter, guck mal, hier, Bane Board, REC-Server.
Rest kannst du auffüllen mit Festplatten und an Shia-Mine,
falls das noch irgendjemand...
Ist das ein Zigbee-Stick?
Warte, ist das ein alter Sixhead-Time?
Sehe ich richtig, ist das eine M2 auf USB und dann darin ein Zigbee-Stick?
Das ist ja mal richtig Next Level Attachment.
Und dann hat er da irgendwie Raspberry Pi Compute Modules drinne, oder was?
Ist das überhaupt ein Zigbee-Stick?
Ja, wer braucht die BIOS-Batterie, Keck?
Und das sind Raspberry Pi Compute Modules, oder?
Storage.
Ja, und brauche mehr Strom.
Exellent.
Easy Sellout, easy life.
Easy.
Easy Sellout.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich sinnvoller.
Wenn es welche gibt, ich habe selbstverständlich,
die 5400 Umdrehungen sind irgendwie meistens schwerer lieferbar.
To spin down, or not to spin down?
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde das immer spin downen,
weil gerade wenn du einen SSD-Cache hast, kannst du den Link zum Videoteil, klar.
Ich mache hier, Chat, Video.
Gerade wenn du einen SSD-Cache hast, dann müssen die Festplatten ja so gut wie nie anlaufen.
Die laufen dann irgendwann mal an, wenn das Zeug rübergeschoben wird,
aber ansonsten sind sie Eidl.
Keine Ahnung, wenn du 4-5 Festplatten dran hast, die permanent laufen 24-7,
das zieht schon ordentlich Strom.
Hi-Fert. Hi-Fert Festplatten-Engineering.
Wow.
Boah.
Lass mal kurz in sein Android reingucken, was er da laufen hat.
Was hat er da am Start? VPN?
Irgendwelche Media-Server-Geschichten?
Was Booksonic ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ach, hier Audio-Audio-Books.
Nextcloud am Start.
Sieht man noch ein bisschen mehr?
Nee, sieht man nicht.
Gibt das? Warte mal, wir machen jetzt mal.
Nein, wir dürfen nicht sehen, was er sonst noch hat.
Was passiert mich jetzt? Man sieht nichts.
Okay, MySQL anscheinend.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Also das ist sinnvoll, deswegen wird es immer, immer runter spinnen, spinnen downen.
Ja, ist so.
Jetzt wird es mal Bescheid.
Wir wissen noch nicht, was wir genau kaufen sollen, aber jetzt wird es mal Bescheid.
Ich habe beides nicht laufen. Ich streame mir irgendwelche Videos von Streaming-Anbietern, wenn ich was gucken will.
Ich habe seitdem, seitdem Streaming-Anbieter gibt, halbwegs erschwinglich, habe ich keine lokalen Sachen mehr liegen in der Form.
Keine Filme mehr, kaum noch Musiklokale.
Time to unsubscribe von Netflix.
Warum?
Just to watch the shows I wanted, I was subscribed to Netflix, Hulu, Amazon Prime, Disney Plus und HBO.
Ja gut, den Wahnsinn mache ich nicht mit.
Max, throw in all the other streaming services and you're looking at more than 100 bucks a month.
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, warum die ganzen VPN-Anbieter so beliebt sind mittlerweile.
Die Leute kaufen sich lieber für 14 Euro im Monat einen VPN-Zugang oder für 8 Euro im Monat einen VPN-Zugang und laden sich den Scheiß illegal runter.
Anstatt sich 5 Streaming-Anbieter zu kaufen.
What? Another dumb original series that destroys the legacy of a franchise I used to love?
Or how about this? This guy bought two seasons of a TV show called Final Space and Amazon just deleted him.
He can't even watch videos he bought all because of a dumb licensing agreement between Amazon and Warner.
He can't tell someone they're buying something if it's actually a rental. It's too much and I am done with it.
Today I unsubscribed for my last subscription, Disney Plus.
But my kids. What do I do about my kids? They love Disney. Disney Princesses, Pixar, Disney shows, all this Disney.
I have to do something to prevent mutiny.
Arrrr, mutiny! Time to sail to seven seas!
No, if I'm gonna do this, I'm gonna do it right.
I'm cutting the cord. Well, figuratively speaking.
But I'm still gonna legally own all the movies my family watches.
And I'm gonna still get HD and 4K content, but with no ads ever.
And I'll be able to watch whenever and where...
Die Kinder müssen jetzt rausgehen und spielen. Nee, das geht ja nicht.
How? Piracy!
No, cut it out, Redshirt Chef. I'm gonna rip it.
In this video I'll show you how I legally built up a library...
Alter! Ja! Das haben die Leute vor zehn Jahren schon gemacht.
...of almost every good TV show and movie my family and I have ever watched.
It starts with this.
In Deutschland ist das übrigens gar nicht legally, weil du Kopierschutz umgehst.
Und das ist nicht legally. Also du darfst theoretisch noch nicht mal...
...deine eigenen DVDs auslesen, wenn du Kopierschutz umgehst.
Ich mein, who cares? Aber darfst du eigentlich nicht.
Nee, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken. Mein...
Erzähl uns jetzt, wie man DVDs rippt oder so. Super. Weiß.
Genau. Das war, wie früher die Leute immer geschrieben haben...
...so nach dem Motto, das ist eine Sicherheitskopie.
Ich habe hier nur mal eine Sicherheitskopie liegen. Ja, ja, ist klar.
Warum ist diese Art von Thumbnails so beliebt bei Call of Duty...
...und anderen Videos? Mit dieser Waffe beim Nachladen vorne?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Ist das irgendwie, sieht das so ansprechend aus...
...dass die Leute sagen, oh ja, ich will sehen wie er reloadet.
Ich klicke da jetzt drauf.
Keine Ahnung, leuchtet mir nicht so genau ein.
War noch so zuvieren.
Das ist alles zu lang. Ich habe jetzt schon Hunger. Guck mal, es ist 11.
Es ist 11, ich könnte jetzt schon was vortan, man.
Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung.
Dafür ist doch die Sicherheitskopie da.
Das, wenn du dein Original verlierst.
Wie läuft es mit der Gewichtabnahme? Es tut sich gerade nichts.
Ich habe mich letztens vor zwei Tagen auf die Waage gestellt morgens.
Da hatte ich 91,8.
Ansonsten irgendwie 92,8.
Das ist im Prinzip das letzte, was ich auf Twitter gepostet habe.
Ist noch aktuell.
Wo ist denn mein letztes Wagen?
Meine Emote-Auswahl ist nicht sonderlich vielfältig, oder?
Ja Wagen, 91,6.
Es ist immer noch das gleiche.
91,8 letzten Morgen oder 92,4 je nachdem.
Ist immer noch das gleiche.
Immer noch so viel Bewegung.
Es ist jetzt ein bisschen kühler geworden.
Ich laufe jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt halb um.
Aber es ist immer noch das gleiche.
Es ist immer noch so viel Bewegung.
Es ist jetzt ein bisschen kühler geworden.
Ich laufe jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt teilweise zweimal am Tag.
Aber im Prinzip ist es ähnlich.
Ich versuche immer noch, dass es im gleichen Bereich bleibt.
Normalerweise bin ich dann immer
Samstag, Sonntag und Montag immer noch größere Runden gelaufen.
Da war schönes Wetter.
Da konnte man auch mal irgendwo hinfahren.
Es lohnt sich das nicht.
Aber solange es nicht mehr wird, ist ja schon mal gut.
Und dann geht es den nächsten Frühling weiter.
Trotzdem möchte ich dieses Jahr irgendwie noch unter 90 kommen.
Habe ich noch eineinhalb Monate Zeit für?
Nee, Schwachsinn. Na doch.
Leute, es ist bald schon wieder Weihnachten.
Seht ihr das? Guckt mal.
Wie fallen eigentlich die Weihnachtstage diesmal?
24. ist ein Samstag. 23.
Alter, wie scheiße liegen die denn?
Alter, wie scheiße liegen denn die Weihnachtstage dieses Jahr?
Guckt mal.
24. 25.
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
Das ist ja kacke.
Das ist ja richtig mies.
Das bringt mir ja gar nichts.
Also, ich habe Montags immer frei.
Also, hier. Alter, das ist ja mal komplett für ein Arsch dieses Jahr.
Guckt mal.
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag bringt mir nichts.
Hier. 31.
Nix. Gar nichts.
Alter, ist das scheiße.
Das ist ja mal richtiger Müll.
Es triggert mich schon richtig.
Es sollte eigentlich gesetzlich verboten sein,
dass Weihnachtfeiertage auf Montag oder Wochenende fallen dürfen.
Ja, selbst Ostermontag sollte nicht auf Montag fallen dürfen.
Kann man ja auf Dienstag legen oder so.
Max beantragt drei Tage Woche. Ich habe letzten sogar kurz überlegt,
wo es wieder um Homeoffice-Thematik geht, ob ich das nicht wirklich mache.
Montag ist dumm. Montag muss ich nicht arbeiten.
Da will ich nicht, dass Feiertage auf Montag gelegt werden.
Was für euch gut ist oder nicht, ist mir doch wurscht.
Ich finde das doof.
Mir geht fast mit der Musik ab.
Ach Mensch, das ärgert mich aber, dass Weihnachten so doof fällt dieses Jahr.
Easy Money.
Ja, ich mache mehr Sellout einfach.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, Leute.
Ich mache einfach mehr Genshin-Werbung.
Was macht Hetzner eigentlich?
Doch, die haben letztens die Rechnung überwiesen.
Also da ist immer noch alles am Start.
Wir müssten mal wieder einen neuen Code machen,
weil der letzte Code ja nicht funktioniert hat.
Einfach krank machen, easy.
Nee, ich bin nur krank, wenn ich wirklich krank bin.
Ja, der letzte ist Corona, zwei Wochen, das reicht.
Ihr wart alle fast noch nicht in einer Wüste, könnte ich wetten.
Ich finde es immer noch witzig, dass sie das freigegeben haben.
Ich musste da so das Lachen unterdrücken bei dieser Geschichte,
weil ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Aber irgendwie hat es keinen interessiert dort.
Der letzte Code ging nicht.
Nee, da war irgendwie kaputt der Max 22 Code.
Wir waren in der Service Wüste, ja.
Da bin ich öfter.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich noch gucken soll, Leute.
Ich habe Hunger.
Und ihr wisst, wenn ich Hunger habe,
ist es immer ganz schlecht.
Neuer Code, please.
Ja, ich muss sie mal anschreiben.
Du machst seit ein paar Jahren HelloFresh.
Nee, ich habe noch was zu essen.
Heute bräuchte ich nicht mal HelloFresh.
Ich habe, glaube ich, noch Reis und Hähnchen im Kühlschrank.
Das reicht jetzt.
Aber ich habe Hunger.
Das müsste ich jetzt...
Aber ich kann nicht um 11.14 Uhr schon was reinhauen.
Ich muss mal zumindest warten bis 12.30 Uhr.
Weil ansonsten, wenn ich jetzt was futter,
habe ich dann abends wieder Hunger.
Also dann muss ich auch früher Abend essen.
Dann habe ich wieder Hunger danach.
Und dann bin ich bald wieder pepo fett, wenn ich mehr futtere.
Jetzt, nachdem ich so viel abgenommen habe.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Ich habe angefangen, Anfang Februar oder so,
hatte ich 108,5.
Alter, stellt euch das mal vor.
Massive pepo fett.
Und jetzt habe ich 91,8.
Da ging schon einiges weg.
Deswegen, ich wollte eigentlich bis Ende des Jahres irgendwie 89.
Aber da müsste ich tatsächlich wohl ein bisschen mehr
Bewegungsgrind machen.
Oder tatsächlich weniger futtern.
Beziehungsweise nicht mal so viel Müll futtern.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe festgestellt, ich kann das nicht.
Also sobald ich versuche abzunehmen durch weniger Essen,
klappt das nicht.
Größe 174.
Moment.
BMI-Rechner.
Ich bin immer noch zu dick.
Zeig mal her.
Wie ist, ich bin?
9.
Simon, warte mal.
38.
Ähm.
Oh.
Aber 92.
Sie wiegen etwas.
Leute, etwas, nur etwas, ja.
Naja, gut.
Und wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen kleiner wäre,
dann wäre ich massive fett.
Ab wann bin ich denn nicht?
Okay.
Hab ich aber Glück hier.
Ihr BMI ist leicht erhöht.
Achten Sie auf Ihre Ernährung.
Bewegen Sie sich regelmäßig.
Ja, was?
Bis 27.
Also, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich 89 schaffe,
dann habe ich, guck mal, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Okay, was müsste ich denn haben?
Wenn man älter wird, geht er dann rund?
What?
Okay, mit 65 ändert sich das auf magische Art und Weise.
Alles klar.
Ähm.
Okay, also, was müsste ich denn wiegen,
dass ich normal wiegen würde?
Warum haben die eigentlich so dumme Slider?
Wo man nichts erkennt.
Alter, das habe ich im Leben.
Leute, Leute, ich komme doch eben leben.
Bis ich mal 80 habe.
Kein Quade.
80, lol.
Ich komme, ich komme lieber auf 80.
Wie soll ich denn auf 80 kommen?
Da müsste ich ja anfangen,
wirklich richtig Sport zu machen und gesund essen
und im Fitnessstudio kreiten.
Ne.
Ne, ne, das kriege ich nicht.
Das wird nicht, das wird nicht.
Zumindest, lasst mal kurz gucken,
was ich vorher gebogen habe.
Wie, das geht noch bis 130, lol.
Äh, 108.
Übergewicht.
Pippo, Massive Pippo Fett, Alter, Leute.
Guckt euch das mal an, lol.
Richtig chonker hier.
Ich könnte, das ist eine gute Idee, Leute.
Ich müsste einfach mal wachsen auf 184, easy.
Okay, da, also Anfang des Jahres war ich
richtig, richtig massiv zu fett.
Das biegt die Gefahr wie etwa Diabetes.
Ich glaube, so ist das nicht gemeint mit wachsen.
Das bringt dir dann auch nichts.
Fang mit Rauchen an,
dann werde ich doch eher dicker als du, ne, oder?
Nice.
Das wird nichts in nächster Zeit,
aber unter 90 dieses Jahr noch.
Rauchen senkt Appetit.
Ja, dafür kriegst du Lungenkrebs.
Ich weiß nicht, was da besser ist jetzt.
Die helfen, indem sie einen BMI-Rechner haben.
Mehr machen die anscheinend ja auch nicht.
Doch, wahrscheinlich erhöhen die da einen Beitrag,
wenn du zu fett bist in Zukunft.
Nikotinspray im Leben nicht.
Im Leben würde ich sowas nicht machen.
Also, dann bewege ich mich lieber noch ein bisschen mehr.
Oder es vielleicht ein bisschen gesünder,
bevor ich Nikotinspray chatte.
Ich glaube euch, das habe ich jetzt für voll genommen.
Ich weiß, wenn man sich anguckt,
was hier teilweise für abgedrehte Dinger holen werden,
dann ist das ja noch das Normalste.
Gehst du eigentlich auch mal aufs Klo?
Nur wenn ich streame.
Aber ich war gestern schon, da muss ich heute nicht.
Essen senkt auch den Appetit.
Ich sehe schon, der Chat hat wieder Massify-IQ-Empfehlungen.
Players outraged.
Players sind heutzutage generell ist es jeder
nur noch über jeden Scheiß outraged.
Ich bin outraged über Leute, die outraged sind.
Du musst Kraftsport machen.
Leute, wenn ich Sport machen würde,
das kostet vor allem ganz viel Zeit,
in der ich nicht streamen kann, YouTube machen kann
oder Sachen, auf die ich Bock machen habe.
Ich bin eineinhalb bis zwei schon am Tag mich am bewegen.
Das muss reichen.
Und seitdem ich das mache, geht es mir insgesamt auch deutlich besser.
Und ich habe massig abgenommen.
Ich mache das jetzt erst mal weiter.
Es muss ja auch nicht schnell gehen.
Gucken wir das nächste Jahr, wenn es wieder gutes Wetter ist,
wie das weitergeht.
Guck jetzt, dass ich dieses Jahr vielleicht
ein bisschen noch unter 90 komme und nicht irgendwie mehr zunehme.
Und dann geht es nächstes Jahr weiter.
Laufband vor dem PC, Quatsch.
So wie Linus. Linus hat das.
Laufband.
Gab mal, gab mal, gab mal ein Video von seinem Büro.
Schon gesehen, CCC.
Nee, zeig mal, was geht es da?
Chaos Computer Club spart dem Gesundheitssystem 400 Millionen Euro.
Lass mich raten, es geht darum,
dass man keine speziellen Router kaufen muss.
Ja, ja.
Ja, das verstehe ich eh nicht genau.
Das ist auch wieder so an Unfähigkeit kaum zu überbieten,
was da gelaufen ist.
Hast du Farben in Siegenden und zu PFC?
Ähm, nö.
Doch, doch, wahrscheinlich damals,
wenn das Video von damals schon gesehen.
Ja, wenn man will, geht das bestimmt ohne neue Kauf.
Aber das ist so ein bisschen wie bei dem Techniker vorhin,
wenn er eine neue Pumpe verkaufen kann für die Heizung,
verkauft er dir eine neue Pumpe für die Heizung,
vor allem, wenn er da irgendwie 20, 30 Prozent Provision vorkriegt.
Ach, ist das nicht, was da läuft?
Leute, das ist echt ein sehr unliebsames Thema.
So IT-Projekte, Internetausbau, Infrastruktursachen in Deutschland.
Da denkst du dir immer, eigentlich haben wir ja theoretisch die Mittel.
Und wir haben eigentlich auch theoretisch die Leute,
um komplexe Sachen umzusetzen.
Ordentlich.
Theoretisch zumindest.
Es ist aber mittlerweile schon...
Eigentlich...
Also, es wird heute standardlich als Witz verstanden.
Also sprich, wenn irgendwie einer sagt,
hier hast du schon gehört, gib neues IT-Projekt auf Bundesebene,
dann denken die Leute, das ist ein Witz, das klappt eh nicht.
Also...
Okay.
Also die Default...
Die Default-Reaktion ist, null klappt eh nicht.
Das ist eigentlich, das musste er erst mal schaffen.
Da haben sie sich hart erarbeitet, die letzten Jahrzehnte über.
Mit Dingern, die ver...
Ich meine, benutzt irgendjemand die elektronische Gesundheitsakte?
Oder benutzt irgendjemand diese ganzen Features,
was du angeblich mit deinem Personalausweis alles freischalten kannst?
Also...
Wir haben eigentlich die Leute,
und wir haben eigentlich auch das Geld und das Know-How,
um das umzusetzen.
Ich...
Die kriegen es einfach nicht hin,
und mittlerweile ist es so, wenn irgendwas angekündigt wird,
lachst du einfach nur noch drüber und denkst dir standardmäßig,
ach, das wird doch nix.
Und leider wird das eigentlich,
dann wird das zu 90% auch nix.
Und ich hab halt den Eindruck, das ist ein...
Also das ist ein vermeidbares Problem.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass einfach die Anreize nicht richtig gesetzt sind.
Also sprich, dass man widersprüchliche Dinge hat.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, sowas, in der Richtung.
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt keine persönlichen Konsequenzen draus habe,
wenn ein Projekt drei Jahre länger dauert als geplant,
ich aber drei Jahre mein volles Gehalt dadurch weiter bekomme.
Also stellt euch vor, ihr habt ein Projekt,
es ist auf zwei Jahre angelegt,
und es gibt keinerlei Verknüpfung an Erfolg.
Und ich brauch dann drei Jahre länger,
ich bekomme richtig Fettkohle,
ich kann drei Jahre länger dranbleiben,
bekomme drei Jahre länger mein Geld bezahlt
und hab keine Konsequenzen dadurch, dass es drei Jahre länger dauert.
Wo ist denn der Anreiz pünktlich fertig zu werden
innerhalb des Budgets, was geplant ist?
Das scheint wirklich der Hauptanreiz zu sein.
Als ehemaliger Geschäftsführer,
Gematik-Schmissprofessor, angeblich IT-Sicherheitsreihenweise raus.
Das wichtigste ist halt, dass die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen,
und die scheinen ja anscheinend nicht zu stimmen.
Wenn die stimmen würden, würden so Projekte auch funktionieren.
Weil wir haben eigentlich Geld,
und wir haben eigentlich Leute und Know-how, um Sachen umzusetzen.
Da sieht man ja auch an anderen Stellen, dass das funktioniert.
Nur irgendwie klappen die ganzen öffentlichen,
sei es Bundes- oder Länderprojekte,
die klappen irgendwie nicht richtig.
Ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen,
dass der eine oder andere Sache auch mal funktioniert.
Aber meistens kostet das einfach nur ein viel, viel, vielfaches mehr.
Und am Ende kommt so Half-assed Shit-Buy raus.
Kann man das aufmachen?
Digitales Hessen.
Diese Seite gibt es nicht mehr.
Ist der Witz, dass es das nicht gibt, oder?
Ist das der Gag, dass es die Seite nicht gibt?
Oder hast du dich vertippt?
Also es wäre ein guter Witz.
Digitales Hessen-Status does not exist.
Tweet gelöscht.
Machen wir mal einen Screenshot.
Was denn?
Also Madminister, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was das sein soll,
was du da gepostet hast,
aber das sollte wahrscheinlich nicht an uns gehen, oder?
Das ist die Leaked-Config aus dem Tweet, okay.
Ach so, du konntest irgendeine Config auslesen.
Von Digitales Hessen.
Okay, zeig mal.
Was ist das?
Okay, was sind wir hier am sehen?
Okay, erst mal Secrets in Plain Text.
Natürlich sehr nice.
GG Eats.
Ich werde immerhin ein gutes Passwort, ja.
Langes Passwort ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas Generatedes.
Und ansonsten bin ich sehend.
Config für was?
Wegen den Web-Service, oder?
DB Passwort.
Das ist ja ausgezeichnet, Ausrufezeichen.
Exzellentes Passwort.
Und das konnte man übers Internet abrufen, oder was?
Die Config-Datei mit dem Datenbank-Passwort im Klartext, nice.
Was wir hier sehen, ich bin mir da selbst nicht sicher.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine Config-Datei für irgendeinen Web-Service.
Für casenjo.de?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Casenjo.de
Willkommen.
Aber die Seite funktioniert mit Darkreader nicht.
Menschen auch im hohen Altersleben mit eigenen Verwenden zu ermöglichen.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Wahrscheinlich verwenden die das...
Nee, die verwenden das auch nur.
Die verwenden das nur, um E-Mails zu verschicken anscheinend.
Es geht hier um was anderes.
CookieDeer, dummy1, HTML, Language.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
E-Mail.
Aha.
Die verschicken irgendwelche Notifications.
Telefonnummern von denen, sehr nice, alles klar.
Was auch immer, das wird es genau...
GPS, Admin.
Ich versuche mich jetzt nicht mit dem Passwort und den Sachen hier einzulocken.
Nicht, dass das noch funktioniert.
So, Admin, okay.
Was auch immer das sein soll.
Irgendwelche... Ist das irgendein Hausnothof oder so was in der Richtung, oder um was geht es da?
Geht da drum?
Naja, mit Sicherheit haben sie es ja oftmals nicht so wirklich.
Den Vorspon einfach ignorieren.
Was ist Digitalisierung eigentlich?
Das Video hat keinerlei Aufrufe.
Ist das von dir?
Ist das Werbung für dein Video, oder?
Okay.
Alter.
Heute, was ist Digitalisierung?
Okay.
Was ist Digitalisierung eigentlich?
Digitalisierung ist eine Möglichkeit, um über Infrastruktur, also die Anwendung sozusagen auf den Glasfasernetzen...
What?
...neue Ideen in die Umsetzung zu bringen.
Was?
Digitalisierung heißt, Anschlüsse und mathematische Algorithmen müssen...
What?
Was? Was so...
Was ist das für ein Satz, Alter?
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Was zum Teufel?
Was ist Digitalisierung eigentlich?
Digitalisierung ist eine Möglichkeit, um...
Man merkt richtig, dass die voll schwimmt und sich On-the-Fly-Bullshit ausdenkt gerade.
Infrastruktur, also die Anwendung sozusagen auf den Glasfasernetzen, neue Ideen in die Umsetzung zu bringen.
Digitalisierung heißt, Anschlüsse und mathematische Algorithmen müssen.
Die Einsen und die Nullen.
Was?
Okay, es hat ja durchaus...
Es hat ja durchaus einen minimalen wahren Kern.
Also quasi klassische Sachen umwandeln in digitale Sachen.
Okay, also analoge Sachen umwandeln in digitale Sachen.
Ja, das ist natürlich rein definitionstechnisch, was mit Digitalisierung gemeint ist.
Was vorher analog war, macht man jetzt digital.
Umgangssprachlich ist damit aber schon eher ja auch Infrastrukturausbau und sowas gemeint.
Aber natürlich prinzipiell definitionstechnisch ist das, man nimmt was, was analog ist und baut es digital um.
Das ist Digitalisierung, okay.
Aber Alter, was ist das?
Random, also wenn ich... Moment, wer war das eigentlich, den wir da sehen?
Wer ist das?
Wer ist denn das überhaupt?
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, wer das ist? Wer ist das?
Ach ja, die Digitalministerin des Landes Hessen. Na, die hat aber Plane.
Da haste nur die Profis am Start hier.
Meine Güte, Alter, was ist mit den Leuten los immer?
Können wir nicht mal an manchen Positionen wenigstens Leute haben, die wissen, wovon sie sprechen?
Gut, ich meine, alleine das bringt auch nichts.
Wir hatten vor ein paar Regierungen, hatten wir einen Arzt als Gesundheitsminister, hat auch nichts gebracht.
Aber gut, ich meine, gerade in dem Bereich wäre es vielleicht nicht verkehrt,
wenn die Leute so ein bisschen Background hätten von Technik.
Die anderen sind wahrscheinlich auch nicht besser.
Also wenn du denkst, nur nicht nach Hessen ziehen, in anderen Ländern sind die wahrscheinlich genauso kacke.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, die ist wahrscheinlich Digitalministerin geworden,
nicht weil sie Ahnung hat von ihrem Fach,
sondern weil der Platz noch frei war und die Partei halt jetzt noch einen Platz besetzen musste.
Und da war die halt am Start.
Aber zumindest mal hätte sie ein bisschen besser auswendig lernen können, um was es da eigentlich geht.
Fax ist, wir haben es doch gerade gesehen in der Config-Datei, SMS ist komplett Hightech.
Vielleicht ist eine Quotenfrau keine Ahnung, wobei ich ganz ehrlich bezweifle,
dass die männlichen Digitalminister-Kollegen mehr Ahnung haben.
Ich glaube, da musste mir erstmal ein Zeichen, egal ob männlich oder weiblich,
von den Ländern Digitalminister, ob es da wirklich einen gibt, der Ahnung hat.
Es ist ja schon die Ausnahme, wenn da wirklich mal einer ein bisschen Plan hat.
Vielleicht gibt es ja welche.
Sie können ja Wörth aufmachen. Mehr geht wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht.
Meine Güte.
Was hat sie studiert? Kommunikationswissenschaften, Pädagogik, Biologie und Chemie.
Das bringt ihr natürlich für digitale Sachen richtig viel, weil man halt da,
auch wenn man da wirklich drin arbeitet, auch mit moderner Technik zu tun hat.
Kommunikation muss nicht wirklich was mit digital zu tun haben.
Ich glaube, da geht es eher um, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, aber ich denke mal, da geht es eher um so
psychologische Sachen, was Kommunikation angeht, würde ich jetzt vermuten.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was sind Kommunikationswissenschaften? Ich gucke jetzt mal nach.
Wissenschaftliche Forschungswissenschaften im Bereich der Soziale und Geist,
die im Vorgang einer menschlichen, ja, Sister psychologische Sachen sind das.
Also nichts, was ihr irgendwie was da gebracht hätte.
Die können Wörth aber nur aufmachen, wenn die Verknüpfung auf dem Desktop liegt.
Ja, das ist wie dieses Meme Video, wo dieser eine Typ seinen Computer löscht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Meme, Computer, das da.
So ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor.
So ungefähr stelle ich mir so die IT Skills der Digitalminister vor.
Die Track und Dropen wahrscheinlich in deutschen Amp dann auch ungefähr in dieser Geschwindigkeit
ihrer Icons.
Dabei in Wirklichkeit wissen wir eigentlich, hohe Effizienz auf dem Desktop sieht so aus.
Und wer jemand behauptet was anderes, ihr wisst, dass es so ist.
Die können oft kein Track und Drop.
Ja, die neue Windows-Task-Leiste kann auch kein Track und Drop.
Erst mit dem neuen Update.
Die haben sich gedacht, da Track und Drop, was ist das denn?
Das muss die Tast-Leiste nicht gönnen.
Legacy Feature, genau.
How to Think Like an Elite Programmer.
Das ist bestimmt Chibated, das Video.
Das ist bestimmt Chibated, aber...
Die Verschiebungen wenden bei Druck und Scan.
Sag mal nichts, gibt genug Leute, die machen das.
Teilweise ist es unglaublich.
Wisst ihr was mich auf der Arbeit auch immer richtig triggert, wenn ich hinter Leuten stehe
und denen zugucken muss, wie sie irgendwas an ihrem Rechner machen.
Und ich denke mir immer, Alter, du musst jetzt da unten, da unten hin oder gib jetzt
mal endlich das ein und er braucht dann fünf Minuten für, bis er das gemacht hat.
Bei der Agentur...
Oh, was hat das Arbeitsamt sich wieder?
Abi.de.
Okay, ich trau mich mal, das jetzt aufzumachen.
Was?
Abi.de, Oberstufe, starte durch.
Schuljahre 2000.
Berufswahl.
Dein Navi zur Berufswahl, was will ich werden?
Oh, das machen wir jetzt, Leute.
Mal gucken, ob ich was mit Holz machen soll wieder.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Also, was interessiert dich?
Sekunde, da brauch ich die passende Musikuntermalung für We Shop Music acht Stunden.
Excellent.
Sehr gut, beste.
Also, zeig mal her, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Was interessiert dich?
Was sind meine Stärken und Interessen?
Welche Auswirkungen?
Moment, ich dachte, man kann...
Wo ist denn jetzt dieses Tool?
Muss ich jetzt den QR-Code scannen dafür oder was?
Okay, ich scanne mal kurz den QR-Code mit meinem Handy und guck mal, wo wir rauskommen.
Der QR-Code geht nicht.
Jetzt.
Abi.de.
Nee.
Hä?
Ich dachte, das ist eine Umfrage, wo ich was ankreuzen kann.
Was sind meine Stärken und Interessen?
Welche Ausbildung gibt es?
Welche...
Okay, Ausbildung.
Hä?
Okay, das ist ja maximal dumm.
Ich dachte, man kann ja irgendwie so eine Umfrage, also so ein Wizard durchmachen.
Er sagt mir am Ende, was ich machen soll.
Web-App.
Gestern haben wir versucht, den Fiat-Champ zu erweitern.
Es hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ja, den Print-Champ, den müssen wir weitermachen.
Das ist ja doof.
Das interessiert mich jetzt überhaupt nicht.
Ich dachte, man kann hier irgendwie...
Was will ich machen?
Das Erkundungstool der Bundes...
Okay.
Das Erkundungstool der...
Das...
Warum soll ich einen Account erstellen dafür?
Warum?
Okay, Check-U.
Auf geht's.
Ich will das jetzt wissen.
Account erstellen.
Kackel.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Passwort.
Was?
Ach so, E-Mail-Adresse.
10-Minute-Mail.
Beste.
Yes.
Okay, Passwort.
Denke ich mir mal an.
Excellent Passwort.
Alter, mein Passwort ist 50...
Ich...
Ihr...
Icker.
Das geht mir auf den Sack.
Ich habe ein übelst sicheres langes, randomizedes Passwort.
Und das funktioniert nicht.
E-Mail-Adresse freiwillig.
Ja, das ist die gleiche E-Mail-Adresse.
So, ich habe eine Nutzungsbedingung gelesen.
Vorlesen.
Was zum...
What the fuck?
Das ist doch...
Das ist doch so gemacht, dass die Bots...
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist gemacht, dass Bots das nicht richtig raushören können.
Geil, Alter.
Okay, MSF, abschicken.
Okay, also ich will den Test jetzt machen.
Lass mich den Test machen.
Wo kann ich denn den Test machen?
Testübersicht.
Ah, nee, ich muss erst mal auswählen.
Okay.
Divers.
1990.
60329.
Bist du...
Ja.
Wie viel Arbeitserfahrung hast du weniger als sechs Monate?
In welchem...
Okay, dann machen wir mal Hessen.
Schulabschluss.
Was machen wir denn mal?
Qualifiziert der Hauptschulabschluss?
Weiter.
Okay, also Fähigkeiten, soziale Kompetenz.
Was interessiert mich?
Berufliche Vorlieben.
Was ist das für ein Five-Hat-Shit, Alter?
70 Minuten, man.
Interessen.
Was interessiert mich?
Okay, berufliche Vorlieben.
Es gibt ja auch verschiedene Berufe.
Welche passen zu dir?
Okay, die obendauer zu lang, das machen wir schon mal nicht.
Wir machen den.
Wir machen den Zehn-Minuten-Test.
Was?
Starten.
Okay, Moment, passende Musik muss wieder angeworfen werden.
Schicken die einem jetzt irgendetwas?
Nutzungskonto, Bestätigung, Serien-E-Mail-Adresse, null.
Mach ich nicht.
Okay, meine beruflichen Vorlieben, weiter.
Welche Tätigkeit finde ich interessanter?
Filmdrehen oder Proben-Analysen, äh, analysieren.
Naja, was YouTube angeht, eher Filme drehen, aber ich drehe ja keine Filme.
Ja, wahrscheinlich eher Proben.
Also rein vom Berufs-Dings würde ich lieber Proben, weil das läuft auf Marketing-Shit
und sowas raus.
Dann lieber Proben analysieren.
Nicht wirklich, aber eigentlich beides nicht.
Übrigens, Chet, ratet mal, was auf Pornhub gerade trendet, auf Platz eins.
Wer weiß es, ihr müsst nicht nachgucken, ich sag's euch.
Overwatch 2!
Was sonst?
Es war so klar, du kannst es einfach schon predikten, dass es trenden wird zur Release.
Also, was haben wir, welche Tätigkeiten finde ich besser, finde ich interessanter?
Handwerklich arbeiten oder Familienberaten?
Was zum?
Okay, auf jeden Fall lieber handwerklich arbeiten, bevor ich Familienberate.
Welche Tätigkeiten finde ich interessanter?
Kurse überwachen, Alter, nichts davon, nichts!
Kurse überwachen, Entscheidung, beides, ich will beides nicht machen!
Was zum Teufel, ich will weder Kurse, okay, Kurse überwachen.
Entscheidungen steuern, was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, ob ich Führungskraft werden will
oder was?
Kurse überwachen.
Alter, was ist das für eine Schwachsinnumfrage, Verwaltungsarbeit ausführen!
Ich will keine Verwaltungsarbeit ausführen, ich will keine Ordner sortieren, vor allem
warum hat der Ordner einen USB-Anschluss, ach man kann auch so weiterdrücken, nee geht
nicht.
Oder Industriemaschinen bedienen, okay Industriemaschinen bedienen, eigentlich auch nicht, aber digitalisiert
der Ordner weiter.
Welche Tätigkeit finde ich interessanter, das geht ja noch weiter, Informationen ausarbeiten
oder Stand organisieren, ich weiß beides nicht, was es bedeuten soll, was ist Stand organisieren?
Stand?
Ach so, von der Messe oder so einen Stand, nee Text lesen ist was für Noobs, äh ja
dann Messe stand habe ich keinen Bock drauf, okay, Gartenmöbel herstellen, Produktionsqualität
kontrollieren, dann würde ich lieber Gartenmöbel bauen, Alter, Verpflegung organisieren.
Alter, ach so, Fernbedienung einrichten, Fernbedienung einrichten, bestimmt besser,
Modell bauen muss nicht sein, next, Finanzprodukte verkaufen Kunden, okay beides nicht, aber
Finanzprodukte verkaufen am besten will ich nicht, Ton aufnehmen, Drehbuch schreiben,
was ist das für eine Umfrage, ja das wäre mir wahrscheinlich das lieber, Sorgen ausräumen
oder reißen, meine Güte, Leute ich könnte mich nie, also ich konnte mich bis jetzt noch
zwischen keinem wirklich entscheiden, es war alles bisher, ich will nichts davon machen,
Reisedokumente kontrollieren, nein ich will weder Reisedokumente kontrollieren noch Sorgen
ausräumen, da muss ich ja mit Menschen zusammen irgendwas machen, aber hier sind es wenigstens
immer noch weniger Menschen, okay, Anbieter finden Netzwerke installieren, ist auf jeden
Fall besser, Bücher vorlesen, Bücher einsortieren, was, ich sortiere lieber Bücher ein bevor
ich anderen Leuten Bücher vorlese, in deinem Freundeskreis hat jemand Schwierigkeiten damit
einen Aufsatz zu verfassen, oh da kenne ich ein paar, aber nicht in meinem Freundeskreis,
aber es gibt genug Leute, es soll darin eine Meinung vertreten werden wofür man dich um
den Start fragt, würdest du eher nach guten Argumenten für den Standpunkt im Aufsatz
oder lieber in Struktur Argumente finden, welche Tätigkeiten finde ich interessanter, Waffelteich
zubereiten oder Verkaufsstand gestalten, Teich, Bäm, in deinem Freundeskreis möchte sich
jemand ein Heimkinosystem einrichten, bitte ich um deine Unterstützung, würdest du lieber
bei der Gestalt, bei der Beschaffung der Geräte helfen, indem du Preise nachlass für die
Kabel verlegen, eindeutig, zwei deiner Bekannten stehen kurz vor ihrem Berufseintritt und streiten
darüber wer von beiden den interessanteren Job haben wird, vielleicht sollten sie den
Job erstmal machen und sollen dann in zwei Jahren nochmal darüber streiten, Daten ordnen,
was, ich will weder Postsätze kontrollieren noch, ok Daten ordnen meinetwegen, Farbwirkung
erforschten, Gemeinschaftsraum streichen, Werbe, Brief ver... ja gut ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste, in Werbeslogans entwerfen bin ich richtig gut, Gruppenkonflikte lösen
auf gar keinen Fall, welche Tätigkeit finde ich interessant, Lichtanlage bedienen, Schaltpläne
überprüfen, wahrscheinlich eher die Schaltpläne überprüfen, nichts, nichts, nichts, Leute
auf beides, niemals, niemals, ich will weder Personen beruhigen noch Theater spielen, wollt
ihr mich verarschen, gibt es da nicht irgendwas für normale Leute, was ist das weder, ok
also ich will, ok bevor ich Personen beruhige oder keine Ahnung was weiß ich, ok dann spiele
ich halt Theater meinetwegen, ne wobei, was ist denn, bist du eher ein Mensch mit seiner,
ich will nicht, ach Gott, ja komm ich beruhige lieber Personen, To-Do-Listen-Möbel aufbauen
ist besser als To-Do-Listen verwalten, kommt drauf an, will ich umfangen, Hammer's bald,
Technikprobleme lösen, Internet Moment, was, gut würde ich beides machen, ok, ok, ok,
Technikprobleme lösen, Buchhaltung verwalten, Forschung betreiben, ja Buchhaltung ist BWL
Shit, Moment, alle Daten gesichert werden können, ja das ist ja was anderes als die
Buchhaltung zu verwalten, Buchhaltung ist was komplett anderes als Backups machen,
das ist so, meine Güte, welche finde ich besser, Partyraum gestalten, Planung überwachen,
gar nichts, aber ich will den Partyraum nicht gestalten, Technik aufbauen, jawoll, Hilfe
anbieten, Hilfe ist overrated, du hast das berufliche Vorleben abgezeichnet, ok, ok,
ok, und jetzt, Testauswertung, meine Fähigkeiten, ok, Testübersicht, was ist denn jetzt rausgekommen,
Testauswertung, ok, meine berufliche Vorleben im Detail, Platz 1, der forschende Typ, Platz
2, der handwerklich technische Typ, ganz im Ernst, das ist gar nicht mal so weit von
der Realität weg, das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht, das ist gar nicht so weit von der
Realität weg, guck mal, ich guck mir unglaublich gern neues Zeug an, probier neues Zeug aus,
ich bastel gerne und ich mach gerne was mit Technik, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt, das
ist wirklich gut, das Ergebnis, Platz 3, prüfende Typ, nicht wirklich verwaltende Typ, kreative
Typ, unternehmerische Typ, der soziale Typ, ja ok, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht, das
hier zwischendrin würde ich vielleicht ein bisschen anders sortieren, aber das hier triffts
und das hier triffts, also Platz 6 ist auf jeden Fall eindeutig korrekt und die ersten
3 sind auch nicht schlecht Leute, alle Fragen wirken weird, am Ende kommt die Wahrheit raus,
ja, nicht schlecht, muss man sagen, ist ok, kann ich mit leben, ist in Ordnung, ja, was
macht denn der andere, wie lang dauert der andere, ok, welche Interessen, machen wir
den noch schnell, komm, dann geh ich aber was essen, dann muss ich, dann muss ich Food
gear machen, je mehr Symbole du ausfällst, desto höher ist dein Interesse für die Arbeit,
anbauen, ernten, kann man es auch komplett weglassen, ok, eins, bauen, basteln mach
ich vielleicht gerne, dokumentieren, ok, vielleicht so, erziehen, nichts, gestalten, entwerfen,
zeichnen, ja, RT-Systeme betreuen, ja wunderbar, kalkulieren, rechnen, ja, ja, kommt noch
mal, für was, im Progasumfeld auf jeden Fall, ich muss was auswählen, ok, Kunden bedienen,
nein, lagern, ja, ja, ja, Maschinen bedienen, steuern ist ok, Material bearbeiten, ja, ja,
why not, messen, prüfen, untersuchen, ja, montieren, reparieren, ja, pflegen, ne, geh
mal weg, planen, organisieren, ja, ein bisschen, programmieren, Porg, reinigen, ja, mal sowas
mit Druckluft aussprühen kann ich, sichern, schützen, beste, Security-Stell, tanzen,
musizieren, gar nichts, geh fort, Tiere versorgen, ja, mein Haustier, aber sonst keine anderen,
transportieren, Fahrzeuge führen, juckt mich nicht, verkaufen, werben, ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste, zubereiten, kochen, ja, ach, ich dachte das war es jetzt, easy, arbeiten
im Freien, würde es dich sehr stören, viel im Freien zu arbeiten, ja, wechselnde Arbeitsorte
nervt mich auch, Bereitschaftsdienst nervt mich auch, ach, Moment, wärst du bereit
in deinem Job, nein, würdest du einen Beruf ablehnen, bei dem öfters Bereitschaftsdienste
anfallen, ja, komm drauf an, wieviel öfters ist, bei uns ist das ab und zu mal, bzw.
1-2 Tage im Monat freiwillig, das ist ok, aber scharf drauf bin ich nicht, Saisonarbeit,
wäre es für dich sehr problematisch, wenn in deinem Job in bestimmten Monaten besonders
viel, das finde ich doof, ja, Schichtarbeit, würde es dir viel ausmachen zu ungewöhnlichen
Zeiten, ja, will ich nicht, Allergien, hast du Allergien wie Asthma, nein, Kontaktallergie,
ja zu anderen Menschen, arbeiten in körperlicher anstrengender Haltung, würde es dir viel ausmachen
körperlich anstrengend wäre, ganz ehrlich, eigentlich ja, aber ich hätte tatsächlich
kein Problem mit, wenn ich mich auf der Arbeit ein bisschen mehr bewegen müsste, als jetzt,
ja, würde mir was ausmachen, wärst du bereit in deinem Job häufig dienstreisen war, zudem
in der Folge bist du öfters nicht zuhause, nein, kein bock mehr drauf, habe ich lange
Zeit, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, bin ich danach runter zu den Schwaben gefahren
öfters, da habe ich echt keinen bock drauf, ja, ihh, Monkees, wisst ihr was ich nicht
verstehe, soll ich auf die Frage antworten oder soll ich sagen möchte ich das machen
ja oder nein, also wisst ihr, dass, auf die Frage antworten, ok weiter, umgang mit Blut,
Körpergeruch, Ausscheidung, also ganz ehrlich, kacke und Blut joggt mich nicht, aber ich
möchte nicht in dem Bereich arbeiten, Verschwiegenheit fällt es dir ziemlich leicht
geheimnis für dich zu bleiben, das bedeutet, ganz ehrlich, was ich bei uns schon auf der
Arbeit mitgekriegt habe, das ist kein Ding, ich erzähle es ja nur euch, sehr egal, ich
erzähle es nur 380 Leuten, den Rest erzähle ich das nicht, würde die Arbeit bei Kälte
oder Hitze viel ausmachen, im rechten Zentrum ist easy, Jacke anziehen, komm doch mal an,
gucken was da passiert, Arbeiten unter Lernen, Versöhnlage, nein, nein, nein, das wage ich
nicht, Arbeiten unter Rauch, Staub, Gasen, Dämpfen, Geruchseinfluss, ja das stört mich,
Tragen von Arbeits- bzw Schutzkleidung, bin ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, Test erfolgreich
abgeschlossen, ok, zur Testübersicht, was kam da raus, Interessen, berufliche Vorlieben,
Testauswertung, zeig mal her, IT-Systeme betreuen, exzellent, sehr gut, Maschinen steuern
und betreuen, montieren, reparieren, programmieren, sichern, schützen, bauen Dokumente, das ist
doch eins zu eins der gleichen Kram, den ich ausgewählt habe, vorher bloß nochmal, was
ist das für eine Auswertung, das ist genau der gleiche Shit, den ich vorher angekreuzt
habe, geiler Test, das ist wichtig gewesen, den brauchen wir jetzt, also bei diesen zwei
Schritten kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, ob das dazu gehört, manch einer würde sagen
ja, aber ich bin der Meinung, alles bloated braucht man nicht, also guck mal, wer fehlerfrei
programmiert, muss schon mal nix testen und wer nix testen muss und keine fehler hat,
muss auch nix dokumentieren, ist doch eigentlich nicht ganz einfach, so ist es, ok, jetzt wissen
wir Bescheid, dieses Tool ist mega hilfreich gewesen, also das erste fand ich nicht schlecht,
der zweite Test war extrem useless, so genug wie Shop Musik, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen,
ich hab Hunger, oder Fooden, wie man so schön sagt, wer denkt, wer der fehlerfrei, wie chat,
wollt ihr etwa behaupten, ich mach Fehler, wenn ich was programmier, das sieht man doch
in meinen Streams, dass das nicht der Fall ist, wo hab ich einmal was verkehrt gemacht,
das könnt ihr mir nicht zeigen und ich stream das live, also keiner kanns widerlegen, easy,
also wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream, selbstverständlich ist der nicht problem, der erholt sich nur
gerade, bad girl macht der 4a-champ gerade, dass er dann gleich wieder richtig loschampen
kann, also Leute, wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut, c u.